uh thank you members
uh good evening members uh officers and
members of the public can I welcome you
to this planning coming to a meeting of
the 15th of March
um just to remind you that we are being
live streamed
as I speak but if you want to see
yourselves on telly it has been recorded
on the YouTube channel as from tonight
and tomorrow
a little bit of housekeeping if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices via the stairs either through
the security door to the left the
chairman or opposite the lifts in the
foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in holy Square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe for you to
return to the chamber
is there anyone here tonight wishes to
film this meeting
could I please show
no I can't see any hands thank you the
Restriction of use of mobile phones
would everybody present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meet is in progress
members requesting to speak under
Council procedure 20.1 and just to
explain that to members of the public
that is councilors themselves who aren't
necessary on the committee
I have on item four
Golf Farm and that is councilor fellows
and item five councilor Pugh as Cabinet
member for regeneration
the following applications have been
reserved for public speaking
oh sorry sorry that's not my list I beg
your pardon counts for Austin
thank you chair I'm sorry I don't have
the agenda in front of me at the moment
because my laptop's slowed to open but
it's the uh it's the uh reserved the
item that's reserved so I wanted to go
to uh Offices please don't worry the
Rams get one thank you thank you that's
Ramsay yes thank you
yeah I want to speak on item 16 as well
uh yes I got you down for that sorry
yeah thank you
oh Council Boyd I didn't see you there
cancer Boyd my arm was going to fall off
then
I'd like to be on item 6B please so
thank you
um I will just check again and see
eyesight up here
public speaking the following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking but members please make
a note on their agenda item 6A All
Saints industrial estate All Saints
Avenue Margate item 6B the old Ford High
Street Garland item 6 C land rear of 20
to 22 Westfield Road birchington
item 6D Gloucester Avenue Margate and
item 6E which is again uh 60 to 68 High
Street and 1 2 11 George Street Ramsgate
thank you
agenda item one I have apologies from
Council right and substituted this
evening by councilor ratican
uh you know glad to see Council of wing
has arrived are there any other
apologies
thank you members
agenda item two are there any members
have Declarations of Interest
thank you and gender item three
one point to update on the provisional
minutes published in the agenda
just to to correct them there and to be
updated to confirm that Maeve Saunders
councilman Saunders sat in as a member
of the committee as a substitute for
councilor shrub at the last meeting and
not councilor towning because we were
aware Council Italian had he was running
late but did arrive in the end so that
is on the meeting of the 15th of
February so if they can be approved
should I have a proposal please
Council Robin thank you a second
councilor Coleman cook do all members
agree
thank you
I'm now going to hand over to our planet
applications manager Mr Livingston who
has several points of information
uh thank you and good evening members um
so I'm just running through some points
of information for scheduled items so
for schedule item 6A this is All Saints
industrial estate clarification has been
sought about the position of an acoustic
fence which has been confirmed by the
applicant and will be shown to members
in the presentation about that item the
plan condition number five will be
updated with reference this plan
for schedule item 6B which is the Old
Forge the councils received comments
from KCC archeology subsequent to the
publishing of the agenda and it confirms
that the archeology report which was
submitted as part of the planning
application which included works that
occurred on site including trial
trenching was acceptable in terms of
assessing the archaeological potential
on the site and therefore condition 11
which required that program of
archaeological Works to occur is
therefore removed from the
recommendation as it's unnecessary
uh now the next two are are some more
important points of information so 6C
which is Westfield Road I'm sure members
have seen in the report uh that the
conclusion of the report is to defer and
delegate to officers for the receipt of
a unilateral undertaking securing the
contribution towards the Sam's project
and therefore what's the recommendation
States approve it's to defer back for
approval subject to the receipt of that
legal agreement okay and the
safeguarding conditions
and the flip side of that is schedule
item 6E which is the High Street and
George Street application so
subsequently printing of the agenda
assigned unilateral undertaking has been
submitted to the council which confirms
the contributions which includes the
Sam's contribution and the other
contributions which are outlined in the
report
that has been received and and agreed as
as valid and therefore there's no reason
to defer back to offices for a
determination therefore it's for members
to determine on the night and the
officer recommendation is for approve on
that application
the other change on that item is there
are two conditions which is conditions 3
and 29 three is surface water drainage
and 29 is about foul drainage and these
conditions are proposed to be updated
um so that they will now read that no
development shall take place on the site
excluding demolition of the building
until the drainage details with respect
to each item have been submitted and
that's to allow for the formulation of
the drainage schemes subsequent to the
assessment
basically to allow the assessment of the
on-site drainage capacity at the moment
to inform that following the demolition
of the building so those two conditions
are updated just with that excluding
demolition of the existing building
clause
thank you chair thank you Ian agenda
item four is a site deficit which I
think members who were able to get along
to Gore in farm minutes Road birchington
I have counselor fellows to speak on
this one as wall councilor Council
fellows you have three minutes
thank you chair thank you members I
oppose the proposed development of Gore
and farm for several reasons firstly the
addition of a third traffic light
sequence will result in increased
traffic congestions and longer wait
times negatively impacting the quality
of life for residents and emergency
services using minutes Road secondly
development would destroy the Heritage
character and unique Farmland character
of the area causing it to become overtly
domestic in nature and as a direct
result lose the rich archaeological
history dating back to at least the 16th
century thirdly the deposed development
will lead to the destruction of local
wildlife and much savored Green Space
resulting in reduced biodiversity and
impacting the health and well-being of
both people and Wildlife
also the loss of privacy security and
views of for residents of the grade 2
listed Gore and Farmhouse it's a
certificate significant concern
I would like the committee to really
consider the benefit of this development
of just seven houses will bring to the
local community versus the irreversible
loss of harm to the agricultural land
Building housing that is Out Of Reach
financially for the majority destroying
the Heritage appearance and farm
landfill of the birchington village I
strongly believe that proposed
development should be refused and the
efforts should be made to protect and
restore the land and buildings for their
originally intended use as a farm I urge
members of the committee to strongly
consider the impact of this proposed
development and carefully to make the
decision that prioritizes the well-being
of residence and the preservation of
this unique character and history of
this area members do the right thing
this evening and refuse permission thank
you
uh thank you very much uh councilor
Fellers I would not just like to say
from myself I know a lot of members of
the committee have received various
emails and correspondents in other forms
regarding this site they don't I can
assure you go unnoticed if you get a
reply but I kind of show you they don't
go unnoticed and they are noted
I find the applications manager which I
believe is in once again will have now
outlined the application thank you
thank you chair so the application is
for seven dwellings are on the site in
Red so this involves the conversion of
the threshing Barn which is go to listed
the conversion of the cartilages
instructor the cowshed four new builds
and a new vehicular access to the site
so this is reported back to members
after the last meeting and just confirm
the motion to approve at the last
meeting was was voted down a new motion
was put forward for a site visit and
clarifications on archeology drainage
trees and biodiversity the agenda item
that's been published before you
includes the officer recommendation to
approve and that follows these
clarifications and that's what's to be
debated this evening so to run through
the plans
um
this is an aerial image of the site
itself
you've then got the proposed site plan
uh including the the new structures and
the conversion of as I say the threshing
behind into two dwellings conversion of
the Cow Shed which is on the road
um to a uh to a single dwelling and then
a separate detached building as well
so the site is within the overall
allocation of SP 16 which is the
Strategic allocation at birchington and
that matter is dealt with in the
principal section of the report
then just a few images of the site
outside so this is a view looking back
towards the traffic lights with the
listed Cow Shed Curtis is the Cow Shed
on the right hand side
and this is the existing traffic lights
going down to the the route that goes
underneath the Railway Bridge and again
the listed structure to be converted on
the left hand side there
and this is down this is the existing
Farm access and you can see the existing
traffic light that is present that I
know a number of members used when
visiting the site that's used for
vehicles exiting uh the the site
um so this is just a view showing that
the full extent of the site uh you've
got the listed building on the site next
door at the bottom of the image and then
the the main threshing Barn in the
center of the image
and this is that that building
and then you've got the view which is to
the southwest corner which is where
there's a current telecommunications
Mast which is outside the site and then
turning to your left from that image
that looks towards the fields and you
can see the the basically the change in
landscape denotes the change in boundary
of the site
and then the view towards the the listed
building next door
so just to quickly go through the
elevations of the proposed development
looking first at the the Curt logistic
building that's on minis Road
this is the existing building itself
what's being proposed is
um and extension to that building that's
that's interconnected at just at ground
floor level behind the existing boundary
wall you've got some alterations that
the building itself it's re it's
re-roofed with chempeg tiles and then
that's the internal elevation looking
out so you can see where there's a
slight connection below the boundary
wall with the new structure to the left
this is the elevation so you can see
that the road level is on the the left
hand side so you can see the change in
level that occurs with the structures in
terms of the visibility from minus Road
and then similarly that's the reverse
elevation showing the road on the right
hand side
so this is the internal layout of that
new dwelling so it's a three bed
dwelling
and then the roof plan
and then this is the the carport and
it's a cycle store as well with some bin
storage in that building as well
and then that's the view of that store
which is uh to the right hand side as
you look at it from the road of that
plot Number One and there's the internal
layout of that
so now looking at the actual conversion
of the list of building the center of
the site itself this is the elevation of
the building
and then the actual conversion works and
themselves so you've got
um on the main elevation as you enter
the site as you look at it sort of
facing west
uh then you've got the side elevation
which is the the north elevation then
the rear elevation which shows the new
extended elements in the center and we
pointed this out on site to members on
the left hand side here you've got the
extension to one of the plots and this
is then shown here so this has been
reduced from the original proposal in
depth
and then the internal layout of those
buildings and then you see you've got
ground floor plan and then there is um
some first floor accommodation obviously
this is slightly limited and just in the
existing roof slope
and then the roof plan again showing
those new extensions it's a sort of
two-story level
so now looking at plots four five and
six
so this is the
um this is the updated elevation which
shows um the actual change in the
cladding and this originally was a dark
weatherboarding but has now been changed
to a lighter
um a lighter large boarding mainly
because of the
um the potential impact it would have on
the landscape by being such a dark
structure previously proposed
and it's the rear elevation so it's
three dwellings in a row of Terrace you
can see the change in uh in changing
roof form there in terms of the height
and also the the design has specifically
been done in in this way to resemble an
agricultural building
and then the floor plans so ground floor
and then first floor
and then the roof plan and then the last
building which is the detached building
um so this is a part Single part
two-story building on the left hand side
here so the furthest away from uh The
Farmhouse next door is the two-story
element so this is so if you're looking
at this elevation the um the the list of
building next door on the neighbor's
property is is to the left-hand side of
this image and then this is the image
with then the neighboring property over
on the right hand side so that the
two-story element is the furthest away
from that listed building
yeah
and then this is the ground floor
and then the first floor so you can see
it's just that element that's two-story
with one bedroom in it
um so in terms of the clarifications
that are outlined in the agenda item to
just run through those
um so the first is with regards to
archeology
um to just confirm a desk based
assessment by the country archaeological
trust was completed and submitted with
the application KCC considered that that
um that initial investigation was
acceptable and recommended specific
conditions for a program of
archaeological Works to be confirmed via
condition there's also a condition eight
which relates to building recording to
occur on the actual listed structure
itself in the center of the site so that
is covered in points 2.1 and 2.2.3 in
the agenda reports in terms of drainage
some of the concerns that were raised
the last meeting I'm sure members will
recall relates to surface water drainage
and indeed in and around that area there
are existing surface water drainage
issues so the new scheme proposes pole
um bound gravel on the site but specific
conditions here are conditions three and
conditions 22 in the recommendation
condition three is the general surface
water drainage condition which will
require details to be provided before
development commences of the surface
water drainage scheme and then condition
22 specifically requires measures to
prevent the runoff onto the public
Highway
those conditions are considered
sufficient with the foul water drainage
condition which is condition three which
is also condition three which would
require details to be provided again
prior to development actually commencing
So the plan in front of you is the um
the landscape strategy plan this
identifies the trees to be removed on
the site so these are the ones in red
that are dotted in red on the site
um the that in total totals 23 trees
obviously members walked around the site
had a look at the trees that were were
present and the proposal includes 23
replacement trees these are covered by
conditions 32 and 33 and the reports the
Agenda Report outlines how 19 of these
are in communal areas and therefore
they're covered by the Landscape
Management plan which does cover all of
the trees but I know members were
particularly concerned about those trees
that were in private Gardens and well
they're not they're likely to stay or
not and that covers only four of the
trees the rest are on the areas to be
dealt with via the management company
responsible for the overall Landscaping
which brings onto the biodiversity
issues which are also shown on this
planet so there is a reptile server in a
bat survey that was submitted with the
application
the application acknowledges the the
loss of reptile habitat on the site but
what's being proposed is a receptor site
which is not to be developed to the
south and north west of the site which
if I skip onto this plan which are in
green here
um
which to provider with specific measures
through a a sort of reptile a reptile
strategy which includes Brash and log
piles and a habanaculum that will be put
set in place as well as specific
strategy for
um effectively reptile trapping to occur
over a prolonged period
um which would basically translocate
those
um those reptiles into the particular
areas as I say to the South and then to
the north west of the site there's also
proposals for back boxes due to the
presence uh of of one bat that was
observed during the survey so you've got
a new multi-chamber
um bat box in the area
um to the north west of the site and
then you've got two back boxes one at
each end of the Terrace row that's
proposed again that's been assessed by
KCC biodiversity to provide their their
professional opinion on whether or not
it Accords with the mppf and it's
considered that it that it does as well
as calling with our local plan policies
so a quick recap on highways matters
you've got the existing traffic lights
as mentioned with an existing traffic
light serving the current access so
there is a proposal here to create a new
access closer to the railway line which
will include uh
a new uh well effectively a move traffic
light so there's a traffic light at the
moment so it's a new traffic light but
obviously there's an existing Traffic
Light present
um this plan is showing the area to be
adopted by KCC highways which includes
the traffic light itself so this new
Junction has been assessed by highways
and is also been subject to a phase one
safety audit and it's been agreed by KCC
that can progress to the next stage of a
section 278 agreement under the highway
act so that we'll look at
um the the details of that access
um which will require further safety
audits to ensure that that access is
safe which is a standard procedure for
new Junctions especially when it's to be
adopted by KCC
um this is a slight busy plan but some
of the concerns that were talked about
on site related to turning in and out of
access
um again to mention that you are this is
obviously going to serve the new
dwellings
um in terms of when traffic is uh coming
in or out of access there will only be
one and one one arm of traffic moving
just to ensure that everyone's clear
there's not going to be any conflict
between vehicles coming from different
directions at that point because
obviously it's it's a traffic lighted
system but obviously it will operate in
the same way that the current traffic
light works is that if things are coming
out of the access then the traffic light
will trigger it doesn't automatically
mean that there will be three stages to
the signals as the existing Arrangement
is and again members that visited on the
site will have will have noted
um how that works at the moment
um so as I mentioned the recommendation
is at the top of the report following
the site visit the officer
recommendation is to approve the
application uh subject conditions
um and that includes condition 36 which
I outlined at the last meeting which
included details of those that traffic
light system to come in and be agreed
with highways um and so it has to say
the recommendations to approve thank you
thank you very much Ian I move at the
offices of recommendation as you've
heard is to approve the vice chair
please second
yeah thank you we I mean we we went over
this we're quite a long debate on this
planning application at the last meeting
I think well I know a larger number of
us are not happy with it for various
reasons
um and obviously that was shown in our
boat to refuse permission and having the
site visit
for those of us that attended it I
believe has has helped me to clarify
why I'm I was a poster and where I am
still opposed to it because
and this is this site visit in
conjunction with me going back
and look at Going Back to Basics really
going back to the local plan
and reading about
um strategic housing site aspect policy
SP 16 and I've read through policy SP 16
a number of times just to get my head
around it and then going on the site
visit seeing the whole site of sb16
it's helped me understand why
policy SB 16 does say it recognizes
the importance of preserving these
listed buildings go and Gore end
and
it also
recognizes a number of the other things
that we've we had concerns about around
around the developments near this edge
of the site needing noise mitigation
there are issues about infrastructure
and so policy SP 16 does say that all
development proposals
but SB 16 it'd be planned and
implemented in a coordinated manner so a
number of the conditions that have been
applied
to this application
just for this little corner of sb16 may
not be appropriate or may be better
served if the whole of sv-16 was dealt
with
in a
in a planned and coordinated manner as
stated in in
um in the the local plan in in the
section on this
because I don't think
this necessarily
gives full adjusted to preserving the
listed buildings it's converting them
into
into accommodations that aren't
necessarily keeping them as they should
be kept they are a designated territory
Heritage assets which should be kept as
such
um and all the other issues I've still
got with this around the ecology around
the highways issues I mean there are I
know the statutory consultees have come
back and said for this little part of
the SB 16 these
um these conditions are okay and they
solve those problems but I think if this
was looked at as a whole site that it
should be I believe in in there's a
local plan that says then there may be
different solutions to this and then but
would likely be able to be able to
deliver the housing that is stated in
sb16 and deal with this important corner
of the site in a better more in a better
way than this application is so I'm
I won't be supporting the recommendation
to approve this application and I shall
be asking for it to be rejected and on
the lines that it doesn't meet
it doesn't meet the um doesn't meet
policy SP 16 so that although the
principle of development for SB 16 is a
good is is there it's not being done in
a way that the local plan says it should
be done and so I I that that will be
what I shall be
um proposing as a reason for refusal for
this uh thank you Council I can bring it
back in I just want to clarify one point
this is saying clarified on the site
visit at the previous meeting
um the motion that was put forward was
to approve and that was voted down the
motion wasn't put forward to refuse the
application so the vo isn't an up down
it's a voting on The Proposal that's on
the floor so it wasn't voted to refuse
the application that's obviously what
will come this evening if that if this
motion that's currently before Falls I
just wanted to pick up a point about SP
um because this this has come up and
obviously it is is written into the the
officer report
um
specifically about this because
um there is the the fact that this
application has come forward separate
from the Strategic um the large major
application that's coming for
birchington
um obviously this the report
acknowledges that
um there is this doesn't come forward as
part with a master plan for the wider
development side this is an issue that
has been looked at before in
applications
um especially the application that
members will recall on on Sterling way
that members visited that was part of
the eurocent site and that policy is in
exactly the same way requires a master
plan to be submitted and that actually
was part of the judicial review which
obviously resulted in council's decision
being quashed and this issue was
specifically looked at as whether or not
actually it should be quashed on that
ground as well in that instance it was
considered that if it doesn't if the
development itself on its own merits
doesn't compromise the ability of the
site to come forward the bigger site to
come forward then you could approve it
it's not an automatic refusal point so
there's got to be harm that's attached
to this now obviously to your point
earlier you've mentioned about obviously
about the impact on the listed building
which is is part of a concern here but I
just don't wanted to clarify that point
it's not just that it hasn't given the
master there's going to be an actual
harm attached to the fact that this site
is is coming forward for development
thank you thank you Ian are there any
other speakers that can swing
uh I won't argue I
I mean I'd I'd also I'd also like to
comment on SP 16 because I think SB 16
involves or should involve looking at
the cumulative impact of how a number of
developments could come together and
potentially
increase the negative impact or the
positive impact on an area and I I you
know this is a very small site I was
grateful to have the site visit because
it did clear up in my mind some things
that were obviously cleared up but then
it made it made me concerned in other
areas
and flooding is the one thing I would
like to pick up on again I didn't
realize quite how low the uh
the underpasses on the railway and I
didn't really realize how how uh the
flooding is quite common there and it
seems to me that we've got this and then
I you look to the rest of the field and
you think there's another massive area
that's going to be covered in houses
which will increase the amount of
surface water because it's presently
open Farmland which water drains through
quite freely
uh you know I accept that that it wasn't
a refusal but but I would prefer to see
emotion that would suggest we need to
see the modeling of the water the
drainage off the site and we need to see
that in relation to the to the other
applications coming forward because you
can't take something in isolation an
sp-16 I think is about looking at the
cumulative impact of a number of
developments and how they may overall
positively or negatively impact on
various things including ecology
Heritage and of course flooding which
we're all concerned about so I I can't I
can't support this application because
I'd like to see it in a in in The Wider
area of of the entire area the whole
site
thank you uh thank you councilor Wing
Council crington
um yeah I really wanted to comment on
the the flooding issue it was actually
quite reassuring to see the site
um as far as flooding from the site
would be concerned
um but I remain concerned that the
entrance that the uh where the traffic
light is going to be is being moved so
close to that bridge which is where the
road flooding is and I suspect and
whilst that's perhaps not for us to
consider but I suspect that the flooding
under the bridge May well cause a
problem to that entrance for those that
are going in and out of it
um those that actually drive through
there may actually know that better than
I do but it's certainly when you look at
the picture
you don't get a sense of just how close
that proposed entrance is to to where
that flooding under the bridges is
happening and also just curiously
wondered can you point out to us where
we found we found the well
um and can you roughly point out to us
where that was because I'm just trying
to translate my on the ground to
um picture
um so um if you've got plot one and
seven so that was where the boundary was
there was obviously some slight dispute
between applicant and neighbor about it
but I think the main the main point is
upper goreen Farmhouse which hopefully
you can see the mouse circling around
um you know it's in it's in it's in this
area here basically obviously so it's
not proposed to be developed on in terms
of footprint of buildings um if I could
just come back on the the drainage Point
again
um this is an issue that's come up
obviously in various appeals including
the shondane road public inquiry in
terms of drainage and consistently the
line that's been taken by inspectors is
that drainage can be dealt with via
planning condition it can be dealt with
through surface water drainage schemes
of which the details are provided
um you know subsequent to approval of
the application and obviously we think
those condition safeguards are
acceptable
um specifically obviously there is a
it's acknowledged at the moment there
are there's effectively
you know from surface water drains from
flash floods et cetera and rainwater
storm events there is currently an issue
in terms of the highway and the whole
aim of the strategy would have to be
that it doesn't make it any worse it
would never get rid of the issue and I
think that's the important Point
um but again it comes back to the point
that
this scheme has to be looked at on its
own merits this is providing
um seven Residential Properties which we
are in a situation where
um you know we are in presumption in
favor of sustainable development that
that new Housing Development has to be
weighed with significant weight against
demonstrable harm and it's all about
demonstrable harm
um obviously we put opposition forward
on this but I just want to make clear
that the conditions that have been put
forward are standard conditions that
you'd expect on development such as this
when there is a surface water drainage
issue outside of the site
thank you in
okay yeah I can't cancel everything
yeah I just wanted to say that um I
understand that members may not like
this proposal but I don't think we're
anywhere closer to hearing a sustainable
reason for refusal from any member of
the committee we didn't hear any last
time we couldn't come up with anyone we
considered it which is why we decided to
go for a site visit and the reality is
that if this committee refuses this
application it will be passed by the
plan in the inspector and the
consequence will be that the taxpayers
of Planet will probably have to pay for
the cost of the process so I should be
voting to support the officer's
recommendation I understand people's
reservations and concerns but I've not
heard anything which will justify a
refusal thank you uh thank you for that
councilor every Council bayford
site visit
affect me in the way it did others
um I believe that the Heritage buildings
have been developed will be developed in
a very tasteful way we set seven
um very attractive properties that was
my main concern was the Heritage that
was lost I believe that drainage issue
has been and the replacement of trees
are biodeaversity the highways issues
have all been addressed and I think like
councilor Everett that we don't really
have any real reasons to refuse this
application thank you
uh thank you I can't see any other
members so I'm going to put it to you
for the vote to those in favor to
approve will they please show the hands
those against
abstentions
I believe that is carried that is
carried thank you members
sorry can I just ask what the vote was
because I didn't I couldn't see everyone
um
it was it was Carrie Council
eight
four one
eight eight
yep eight yeah
[Music]
so as you've got the members and members
of the public that has been approved
thank you
moving on to agenda item five this is an
update for unit one and two belgrave
Road Margate I don't have any public
speaking but I have a councilor Pew as I
mentioned who is cabinet member for
regeneration
cancer puke
thank you chair
um
I know and and members will planning
committee members will know that this
plan application came to committee last
month and I don't want to to rehash and
go on and repeat what I said at last
month's planning committee
um subsequent to your decision the
applicant has gone away and made
amendments
um I stand by the comments I made at the
last planning committee meeting I think
that the previous design and the scheme
was incredibly bold
um I think it's what's needed
particularly in Margate and I think we
need to think a little bit outside the
box
and it's important that we encourage
development of Brownfield sites
particularly in our town centers
changes have been made to this
application the applicant's been
incredibly Keen to overcome many of the
hurdles and the concerns that planet
committee members raised last time
um the color scheme has been amended the
changes to the back have been put
forward as well I know that's one
comment that was made before and that
the overlooking issues to the side of
the property in relation to the property
that's already there on Marine Gardens
um the overlooking issues have now been
resolved
I understand from the applicant as well
that the applicant is willing to provide
full contributions
um through section 106 that could be
tied up in a legal agreement the reasons
for refusal
um
particularly
second reason with the legal framework
you know if the planning committee is to
approve approve this application then
you know that can be tied up in a
variation or a subsequent legal
agreement I don't necessarily think that
that should be a reason to refuse this
when it can be overcome if the planning
committee want them to
um
the first reason for refusing on the
height I'd like to reiterate again if I
don't want to Hash over it you know that
Margate has a very varied uh Building
height across the entirety of the town
you know behind this uh to the back of
this the back of Dreamland is Arlington
House I find it astonishing that we can
try and refuse the scheme of of four or
five stories or even six stories of this
height when we've got Arlington house
behind us I'm not advocating that we
tear down Arlington house but I think
it's just important that we notice and
understand that you know in the grand
scheme of things this isn't a
particularly tall building in relation
to other things
um
again the concern particularly with the
conservation area you know I think we
need to be bold I think we need to
appreciate that this is a landowner and
a developer that wants to come in and
create something unique and different
for Margate and I think that
particularly the entrance to Dreamland
across the road I think it deserves
something better than is currently there
if I'm quite honest and I would
reiterate again
um how important I feel it is that we
encourage people to move back into the
town centers that we we have more
housing development in our town centers
particularly in the hope that it means
that we have to build Less on
agricultural Farmland I think that's
really important
um
to summarize and I will be quick
apologies chair bear with me
um I know that the applicant is willing
to overcome many of the reasons the free
reasons for refusal that have still been
for recommendations for refusal that
have been put forward
um I think continuing dialogue should be
maintained and particularly the the
legal agreement all of that could be
tied up in a condition and if quite
honestly if you don't like the color
again then we can have a vote today
um and you can put that in as a
variation or a condition but I hope that
you will approve this thank you
uh thank you Council Pugh with pop-up B
and Q afterwards um
[Music]
thank you chair
um
so
yeah very brief reminder the application
is for uh site in belgrave roads so it's
for three commercial units at ground
floor with a three-story extension above
with 10 Flats
so this was deferred to officers to see
commitments to address concerns related
to the impact on character appearance
the area some of those points that were
raised have been summarized in the
agenda report and as already outlined we
have received some amendments but I'm
just very quickly going to run through
just a bit of context so
um site is within the market
Conservation Area is opposite the
Margate seafront Conservation Area
you've got the list of buildings next
door 12 and 12 a which is to the north
of the site
um then you've got a an allocated
housing site to the rear which is dealt
within the report
so just reference of Eaton Hill here in
belgrave Road here with Marine Gardens
at the top
so this is the building
it's a view further back
then we've got to view the other side of
the other side so you've got the listed
building on the left hand side
listed building from the front
across next to the Clock Tower
this is the view of the the rear of that
list of building so you can see the
distance between the the existing
building and the rear of the list of
building
then this is a view down from Eaton Road
so you can see the listed building here
and you can see the the Gable of the
existing building which is to be
retained and built above
and then this is a view down Eaton Hill
so this uh single story sort of
Warehouse Star Building is outside the
site so the building will be behind this
and we'll look at that in some images
later
so this is the image of the the scheme
as it was put before members
um so just on this it's just important
to look at the change that's been made
in terms of the actual materials itself
um the CGI has changed in terms of its
aspect with uh buildings adjacent to it
but I just want members to focus look at
the change in materials that have been
proposed so when I say changing
materials I really mean the color has
changed so the materials are the same
the cladding on the on the sort of
element at the rear and at the top floor
the fact that it's um you know it's it's
a brick facade a first and second floor
but it's now got a brick facade at
ground floor rather than painted because
it was as you can see the dark paint
that was on there it's now with the uh
the brick at the ground floor the
signage also across the top has has also
has also gone
um so just going through some of the
other changes quickly so we've got the
proposed sorry the existing block plan
here and then this is the new uh the new
roof plan and we'll look at the changes
that have been made on the northern part
of the building next to the list of
buildings as we look at the elevations
so
this is the elevation as it was so again
what's changed here if I click it the
signage is gone and there have been some
changes that have been made on the left
hand side here so the balcony at second
floor level previously extended the full
width of the building that's been
reduced and that's to deal with the
overlooking issues that that officers
raised as well as some changes at the
the sort of the roof level as well to
accommodate some some floor plan changes
which we'll look at
um so the existing South elevation of
the buildings have again facing towards
the back of the list of buildings there
um this is what was proposed now this
hasn't changed in scale
um so this building this this view is
exactly the same scale ignore the fact
that it's just moved but it's just to
confirm on the ground floor it's now
brick rather than the the painted dark
painted facade
then the rear elevation of the building
at the moment
so this is where some of the other
changes have occurred so members will
recall there were the the metal cross
braces that were that were there so
what's changed now is that it's now
yellow rendered with cladding and we'll
look at that on CGI which will show you
it um a bit clearer
foreign
elevation which doesn't change that
accesses those Flats at the upper levels
and then this is the elevation that's
changed which is the north this is
looking with the list of building behind
you looking towards the the side of the
site
this was the original proposal so you
can see the second floor balcony that's
here
and it's slightly changed again you'll
see it on the CGI a bit better with some
changes that have been made there as
well
um so this is the section of that
elevation so you can see there was a
Terrace on this second floor area that
has now been removed as part of the
amendments
so this was uh the existing and then the
previous scheme and then this is the new
scheme
uh and similarly that is actually just
the new elevation but obviously as I say
that doesn't actually change the size of
the structure itself
so the existing floor plans ground floor
and roof plan existing ground floor plan
so this doesn't change for the previous
proposal so you've got two smaller units
and then one larger commercial unit with
resonance parking at ground floor you've
got bin storage and cycle store on the
left hand side with the stair core at
the rear that accesses all the flats
so then this was the original first
floor plan and so what you've got here
is you can see the balcony is open for
this unit at the front here all the way
across the frontage which would have
allowed someone to stand in this area
here and have in our view direct views
into the windows of the neighboring
property
so what's been proposed here is that
internally where the mouse pointer is
that there would be a one 1.1 meter high
wall so the same height as the ballast
trading at the front but on the return
to strike to stop access to this area as
well as that these are windows here
within the living areas they're not
doors that are proposed now as you'll
see from the report
um whilst this is welcome to restrict
physically try and restrict access to
this area and this applies to the third
floor plan as well it is considered by
office that you do need privacy screens
of some sort because that in itself
isn't considered to be necessary just if
if someone wanted to use and get the
best views of the sea which is what this
balcony part would provide it's our view
that you'd also need a condition to to
require previously screens but as the
report outlines
the combination of a condition for
privacy screens and indeed the internal
sort of the floor plan changes are
enough to overcome the reason for
refusal which is why it's not
recommended to refuse the application on
overlooking now in part that comes from
the removal entirely of the second floor
balcony on the left hand side so you can
see that section is now gone there's no
there's no balcony in that section
and then on the third floor
again much more difficult on the third
floor
but you have got again a restricted
inner wall at this point here next to
the hashed area where it'd be 1.1 meter
in height to avoid people going to the
full extent of adjacent to the the
neighboring building
and then this is the the new roof plan
um so just to look at the cgis again
mainly just in terms of the palette of
materials
so again that's the change in the
palette on that view
this is the view that's been provided
um obviously from Marine Gardens
and you can see so the material so you
can see the change that's now occurred
here so you've got no balcony at this
area
um again you can see the change in
materials
and then the rear
so what's been changed here is obviously
as I say it's it's more open uh with the
panels that that are present
so
as as has already been mentioned by
accounts the Pew the applicant has
confirmed that they are willing to
provide the contributions requested uh
within uh the the report and the heads
of terms um
we have received a draft unilateral
undertaking
um for the security of those
contributions
um however it doesn't it doesn't
actually secure those obligations there
are a few checks that need to be done
about land ownership various different
things so we're not in a position to set
that reason for feudal has been overcome
at this stage however if members were
minded to approve the development as
I've already outlined in other points of
information it's entirely possible to
defer back to officers for approval
subject to the legal agreement coming in
that secures those obligations so it's a
technical reason for refusal if if
members refuse it this evening that it
would be refused on those grounds but it
can be overcome if members considered
that that first reason for refusal isn't
a reason for fees you want to you want
to refuse the application on
um the office of you though on the
proposes whilst the living conditions
issue has been dealt with it is still
considered to be a development that is
too high
um it does in our view have it in
Congress and dominant overbearing impact
specifically in regards to the setting
of the list of buildings on the
left-hand side of the image that you can
see as well as the hierarchy of
buildings in the conservation area both
the Margate Conservation Area and the
Margate C fund conservation era and
obviously significant weight has to be
given to any harm to designated Heritage
assets therefore that has to be weighed
against any benefits that do accrue from
the development and it's acknowledging
the report that there are benefits from
the Redevelopment of this site and the
provision of 10 residential units in
this location but the office of view is
that that balance hasn't outweighed the
harm and therefore the recommendation
from officers is is still to refuse the
application thank you chair thank you
Ian I moved the offices of
recommendation is adopted and I share
please second
members
a few hands going up cancer crinden
as I said last time I love the design
um I love the orange and green I thought
it was great I thought the word the
lettering on the roof was a little bit
Naf but um I don't know if that's a
technical term or not
um so I'm quite pleased to see that gone
I can live with the more muted colors
um the rear view is better than the um
slap in the face like a wet Kipper that
was the original design and I still like
it
um so I don't actually have any
questions or challenges on it the only
thing I would add is that I was very
disappointed
um to see that item number two the
applicant had failed to enter into the
legal agreement and it just felt like
the applicant has kind of rushed back to
committee a little bit without actually
having ticked all the boxes and I think
that's my only only concern but apart
from that I still like it
thanks very much Council bayford
thank you I I agree I I like the
original
um I I think we really do need to
encourage Investments the area and the
provision of housing however changes
have been made to meet the concerns of
members and I think for that reason
I cannot see any reason to reject this
thank you
thank you councilman
well thank you chair how kind
um
as the as the
member who asked for this to go back to
offices for
um to get some further information and
see if they'll change I'm pleased I'm
pleased with what I'm seeing
um yes it is a bit a bit bulky but
um when you look at it from the front if
you stand in front that listed building
you won't notice the bulk that's my
opinion
um
I
I can't accept
uh that we should refuse this
um I can't accept either that because
someone's putting money in the area we
should just approve it I mean that's
that's rubbish we shouldn't be looking
at anything like that but what we should
be looking at is what it's going to
provide for Margate and what it's going
to provide
better than what is there than what is
there now 10 new dwellings new shops on
the ground floor yes it's a bit
different
um but I'll fully
support this application against the
officer's recommendation thank you Chad
thank you Council Auburn and I couldn't
see you behind cancer Crittenden so any
other
councilor pull more
yes thank you chair uh I think the
developers listened to our concerns he's
made amendments to make it more pleasing
and blend in and I think the quirkiness
of the building Blends in with the
arcade scenery that we've got there
which is part of what Margate is it is
changing a Brownfield site in to sue to
accommodation and to commercial use so I
don't agree with the officer's
recommendation refusal and I'll be
putting forward for approval
as it seems many people
approve or can we just clarify
um do we need to put in a condition as
you said about the um you know as we
haven't got the assurances we need I've
got to put it to the vote First Council
keen and see what happens then and then
I will come to Mr limousine but thank
you for that I do understand thank you
any other members wish to speak
Council everything
yeah I just wanted to comment comment
slightly facetiously with the the
previous rear of the building looked
like a football stadium to me you would
know metal cross prices which I do have
some knowledge of
um and so I think that um it doesn't
look like that now which is probably a
good thing because I don't think uh what
appeared to be a football stadium in the
middle of Margate was necessarily a good
idea thank you
I can't see you standing there watching
football anyway
uh yeah I know okay uh thank you members
um okay well I'm cutting for this I have
to sue the votes um
which the office of the recommendation
is to refuse
those who accept that other please show
their hands
those against
right abstentions
that is
and I just said
um I'm sure thank you
thank you
um that motion has been lost so once
again I turned to Mr limerson please
thank you I think members of the
majority members are made it quite clear
about
um they find that the change of the
design acceptable so in line with what I
was saying earlier
um in terms of what officers would then
recommend in this instance in terms of
emotion
um that the the motion that the most
appropriate would be in our view to
defer and delegate
to officers for approval subject the
receipt of an acceptable signed
obligation securing the required
planning obligations and safeguarding
conditions because you'll see from the
Consulting views there are quite a few
other Consulting comments about
different conditions that are needed and
that would include privacy screens to
the northern balcony boundaries and
that's on the grounds for the economic
and housing benefits outweigh the
limited impact as members have
considered it on conservation air and
adjacent list of buildings
uh thank you Ian um you've heard
obviously your answers I hope um I need
a proposal for that which is councilor
Alban your proposal of that chair
obviously exactly what Mr Livingston
said subject to section 106 agreement
coming in uh for for approval
um yeah as you said Thank you again said
uh secondary councilor bayford do
members agree agree
and show fans please
anyone against
obsessions
to abstentions
uh thank you very much members for that
agenda item six is just to tell you
about
um
sci-fi so if there are any site visits
decided tonight they will be on Friday
the 31st of March
a little bit earlier than normal it's uh
I think we know what's going to happen
next
always say next week all right I've just
been told it's a good Friday after that
so um happy Easter and so on
uh agenda item 6A
um All Saints Avenue industrial seed or
Saints Avenue Margate speaking against
the application is a Mr Hodgman are you
there Mr German
you are you have three minutes if you
can please
okay so the um the applicant is uh
put in for 58 units on this site
which I think is too many for the size
of the site
um to squeeze that many in they've
adopted a sort of cul-de-sac layout
which is creates some sort of dead ends
if you look at the
if you actually look at the the site
plan
um the distance between the uh the new
warehousing the actual road is gonna be
five and a half meters wide
which is nowhere near wide enough for
this for this I don't think the um the
report acknowledges the fact that large
Vehicles large commercial vehicles will
be visiting this site including waste
vehicles and delivery vehicles
um the waste Vehicles apparently up to
about 13.5 meters long
now if
if a 13.5 meter long vehicle
goes into the site and it's in a road
it's only five and a half meters wide
there's no way that's going to be able
to turn around it's going to have to
back out
and we're talking about a distance of
I've actually measured it took 150 to
200 yards reversing that is dangerous
that is dangerous and that really should
not be allowed there was a previous
application
for this site sort of similar in some
ways but larger buildings but quite
dense but it did have a a Perimeter Road
right around the development
and that sort of then meant that
everything could drive in and drive off
the estate that's what's required here
this this is wrong and it's going to
cause
it's going to cause accidents this is an
accident waiting to happen like this
that needs to be changed it's
you know I accept it would mean the loss
of a few of the units but
this is just not right
thank you
uh thank you very much Mr hogman uh
pastry between once again for the report
thank you chair
um so this is the application that was
previously reported to members in
December so it's an outline application
for 58 light industrial units
um including all details except for
landscaping within this outline
application
so previously in December uh members
defer back to officers seek additional
information on turning within the site
and a reduction in the number of units
to increase parking and turning
available so we've I'll come back in a
second so we have received amended plans
with eight additional parking spaces but
with no reduction in units so the site
is allocated as employment land in the
local plan so it's supported in
principle under policy you see one I'm
just going to remind members of the site
itself so this site is the large sort of
hard surfaced area the tree perimeter
that runs around rep properties on
Railway Terrace and Tivoli park avenue
runs along the the side of the site
going through this is the vehicular
access onto All Saints Avenue
um
which should be redone as part of The
Proposal
this is looking back towards the
existing access
just to talk a bit about railway Terrace
these properties are set up from the
ground level on this site and so I'm
going to show members some photos of
that you can also see how the site at
the moment has
a hoarding that runs that means you
can't access that site at the moment
which runs along and includes this
triangle of land which we'll talk about
in a little bit so this is an image just
showing you can see the corner of the
dwelling there so you can see the sort
of change level we're talking about
and then this is a view when the holding
starts so you can see that there's a
quite changing level with those
dwellings these are the front elevations
of the properties on Railway Terrace
and this is another view so you can see
the axis at the moment is in a a pretty
poor state
so this is a view looking back towards
those trees at the back of those
properties on Railway Terrace and you
can see again the hoarding that's
restricting access to the site
and then this is inside the site so the
hoarding is on the right hand side of
the image there and these are the trees
that are with with the Residential
Properties behind
this is just a detailed view in so again
you can see that that significant change
in level
then this is just a view showing um the
rear of the properties on uh Tiffany
Park Avenue and we're going to have a
look at the boundary along there you can
see it's got lots of existing
Landscaping which is supposed to be
retained as part of the development so
again you can see there's a quite
significant Bank
where the trees are located
and this is a longer sweep of those
trees
and again you can see the change in
level that occurs these are the the
first floor
um bits that you can see there on those
properties
um
and then this is a view looking back
towards those trees again
and so just look uh you've got an access
that runs inside the site that runs the
rear here which is obviously used as
open storage and then a view around to
the back and you can see existing
businesses which use the the current
access as well as their access to rear
so you've got this is the all-access
area here for open storage so this is an
access that's in the site that we'll
look at on the floor plan on the site
plans so as mentioned
um
there is a previous approval on this
site which was 2016.
which approved a uh
three uh light industrial units under
his class as it was B1
um with the blue part of the image on
the left being uh General industrial so
you can see the arrangement that was
proposed in that instance as mentioned
was was parking alongside and then a
route that ran around
site and you can see in a bit more
detail on the image on the right hand
side so the principal development was
was found to be acceptable so the
proposed scheme does similarly in terms
of keeping the landscaping or proposing
to keep the landscape not developing
that on the site so this is the revised
plan and we'll look at in detail what
has actually changed because primarily
around the access and the parking
available before you actually get into
the site itself
so looking at it in a bit more detail
this was the plan as it was submitted
you can see this triangle here of land
which was shown with just a couple of
parking spaces on as well as an area
alongside the the trees alongside the
access you've got under this cover here
the proposal for four spaces here and
some van parking with five spaces here
what's been proposed is to add eight
parking spaces to this area for General
parking use and there's also some
parking that's been lost at the bottom
which apologies won't necessarily be
able to see but in the middle of the
image there's a couple of space have
been effectively moved round so they're
outside of that internal area and
they're in this area here for for
General parking which has been which has
been put forward
um so just to go through the detail bits
of the the site plan as well so you've
got
um in total
um you've got 146 spaces serving all of
the units you've got two dedicated
spaces for each of these units
themselves you can see on this plan uh
the the gray retaining wall to be to be
erected which runs along the bank so you
can see this is the large Bank area that
we looked at on the photographs
you've got then the access road that
runs down all the way to the other
business which where we looked at the
image which is down at the bottom of
this plan
um so just to look at some of the
elevations
um just to show the type of of
desired buildings so we're looking at
metal Cloud buildings they're two-story
um in terms of having mezzanine levels
the
side elevations
uh brick elevations
um and then I'll just show you the
middle section of buildings
just to give you notice the middle
section of buildings where you've got
actually the long run this is what
you're looking at so again you're
um
you know it's open at the moment but I
know there's a query about mezzanines
that we talked about last time
and these are some of the other
elevations so there's all very similar
design
so just to pick up a point regards to
Turning so at the moment any large
Vehicles including any arctics that
serve the existing buildings uh sorry
existing businesses such as the tip of
suppliers have to use this triangle of
land here to turn around that is not
changing this proposal will not change
that it will not restrict access to this
area
and this is the area in question
um so that we have had a submission of
plans that show how turning of an Arctic
occurs or could occur at the moment and
this does not propose to alter that
ability which also would obviously
include the ability of of vehicles which
would as as mentioned have to
effectively if if there was a
significant scale vehicle that was
accessing one of the units for whatever
reason even though these are very small
units then they would have to reverse
down the access road internally in the
site to then be able to turn around in
this area
highways have looked at specifically the
impact on the highway Network because
it's got to be the severe harm to the
highway Network to be refused on a
highway ground and because there's the
ability to turn within the site and
leave using a forward gear there is no
objection from highways on that basis
and indeed this does not make the
situation any worse than the current
turning Arrangements that are on the
site for the existing businesses
um in terms of the relationship with the
neighboring properties
um one element that wasn't requested by
members but has been added is um is an
acoustic fence that's been proposed
which would run the um the site side of
these trees
um and you can see it which is shown on
this plan here so you can see that there
is proposed to have as well as the
retaining wall then there is to be a two
meter acoustic fence it's not considered
by officers that is necessary by virtue
of the fact that there are conditions
proposed which would restrict the
opening hours of these units so they
would not be able to be open on Sundays
and they wouldn't be able to be open on
Monday to Friday or Saturdays past at
six o'clock and not be used on that
basis
um there is obviously the issue of
um the the changing levels which means
that it's considered biases that there
is an acceptable relationship in terms
of distances from from different
different properties
um
and then this is just the section of the
retaining wall
um
so overall The Proposal provides
um 58 units on an allocated employment
site so it is there is tangible economic
benefit that needs to be weighed in
favor of the development as I mentioned
highways have had no objection to the
proposal and it does include
improvements to the access including a
new pedestrian footway along the north
of the site which obviously isn't
present at the moment
um
and there are on Street controls at the
moment along All Saints Avenue and
therefore
um whilst I appreciate there are some
concerns about the internal movement of
vehicles it's not in office's view
possible to demonstrate that there's
severe harm to the highway Network by
virtue of this proposal
as I mentioned due to the changing
levels and also the planning conditions
it's considered there is a significant
harm to neighboring properties and
therefore the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to
planning conditions outlined in the
report thank you thank you Ian I moved
the officer's recommendation as you
heard was for approval Vice chair please
second oh second nature thank you
councilor common cook members councilor
Auburn yeah thank you chair
um I did actually mention acoustic
fencing the last time during the last
meeting so I'm just saying that just
reminding you
um
I have to say I still think the site is
cramped
uh I think that the
the top eight units as they obviously
hadn't listened to what to what we were
saying uh I I
don't think that they should be there
that solves all the problems with
relation to the neighboring residential
properties
um
and they could have spaced that out a
little bit more and as our resident said
that would give him a little bit more
turning space as well
um so I have to say chair I don't think
I can support these officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you Council crindon
thank you very similar I remember we
discussed this before and we said that
there were too many units not enough
room for maneuver we did ask for extra
parking spaces and they have done that
and we did ask about the Acoustics and
they've done that
but rather with the resident What the
residents saying I'm concerned about the
Turning of large vehicles
um what happens if two turn up at once
sorry that's just my thinking
um One's Gonna have to back out uh I
think it's I think it's over development
on that and I'm sure that there's a
better way they can can do this
uh thank you
Council King
has any um figures been put forward to
estimate the amount of movements there
would be of that many units
okay
about the the overall number of units or
the those end units so I didn't quite
catch you
the overall number of units uh picking
up on councilor christenden's point of
two turn up at the same time given that
we are developing many more units on
this site have they provided any metrics
around a assumed usage
um so there is there was a transport
assessment that was submitted with the
application which did include movements
and specificities looking at the
junction the current Junction accesses
All Saints Avenue in terms of existing
visibility sprays potential for
vehicular conflict as mentioned in terms
of the ability of of vehicles to to pass
on on that that Junction again highways
have have stated that there's there's
not considered to be severe harm to the
network on on those specific grounds and
the level of parking that's provided is
sufficient
on the site I think just to pick up on
some of the points that have been raised
in terms of that there are too many
units on site I think the concern from
officers is that that's that doesn't
result in tangible harm to either as I
say the highway Network in terms of
we're not supported by KCC highways on
any refused on that ground as well as
that this is a site that doesn't have a
defined character this is not a um it's
it's very very difficult to argue that
there's harm to the character and
appearance the area by virtue of the
number of units on this site it's it's
an employment site it's not a
residential site and the concern again
has a major development uh an
application which obviously is um
potential ramifications in terms of an
approval by an inspector that the
benefits of of the number of units
whilst obviously appreciate what members
are saying about there are too many of
them and they could have resolved the
concerns that you've got on balance it's
it's our view that the benefits do
outweigh any any
concerns with regards to the particular
issues do with turning on the site
thank you Council wing uh I'm quite
concerned thank you about impact on
neighbors so I think it goes back to the
the number of potential vehicle
movements on site and the size of the
vehicle movements on site so we have
some residential homes and the number of
units on site has been significantly
increased uh we have to make the
assumption that the vast majority of
possible Vehicles visiting that site
particularly the largest ones are going
to be diesel vehicles uh throwing out
particulates
and a diesel vehicle a large diesel
vehicle attempting to back up to either
deliver at the bottom or then and then
re reverse back up to get back to that
turning point is going to obviously
create a significant amount of noise
backing up and also a significant amount
of particulates and pollution that could
well impact the the surrounding
neighbors so I I I would much the the
previous scheme where Vehicles went in
and out so there was a route in and out
which would mean a continuous flow
rather than this attempting of a vehicle
to back up
would be a much better a way to try and
reduce the impact or the potential
impact on on those houses there and the
surrounding environment so I I can't
support this plan in its present shape
although I agree that we need smaller
units
thank God so we can bring back in front
just just on the point we've got air
quality there's an air quality
assessment that was submitted with the
application which looks specifically at
vehicle movements and receptors both
pedestrian receptors and also residents
in and around there that was assessed by
the environmental health Team and it was
considered that there wouldn't be
um it was within an acceptable range
without harming human health and so
again in terms of
demonstrable harm to outweigh the
benefits there is obviously expert
advice that's been provided to to state
quite clearly that there wouldn't be a
tangible harm that could be weighed
against it again on the basis and it's
in the officer report and as well the
the environmental health concerns are
are in there so whilst vehicle movements
will have of course increase above the
level at the moment because the site is
just open uh it's not to an extent that
it would cause any impacts with regards
to health with regards to air quality
and specifically even with Vehicles
reversing up there which obviously is
the aim here is to avoid it by keeping
that turning area open thank you
councilman you wish to come back yeah
thank you chair I just want to make it
clear that this is a well needed
area for for these kind of these kind of
units we I mean it's a perfect place for
them apart from a bit on the top and I I
didn't want it to sound nitpicking but I
do think they use their Loaf and removed
those ones that those ones at the top
there wouldn't be any issue with it at
all for any of our for any of us members
in it I specifically have the concern in
relation to noise emissions from the
units even though they may be deemed to
be a light light industrial units
um
have you been on many uh or many
industrial site like light industrial
units uh China doors are open during the
summer bang everything like that and I
know there's conditions to restrict
hours but you know that's that's
I still think it's not good enough
to approve it thank you thank you
councilman Council Williams
thank you yeah um one thing that Springs
mind is with 50 units there you could
easily get more than just one or two
lorries there so it's not going to be a
problem with two it's gonna be a problem
with maybe half a dozen even more of an
issue looking at it is
um it's an industrial unit so things
could happen and the fire engine might
be needed fire engines on so articulated
they're going to have great trouble
getting in and then getting out
okay so for safety reasons alone it's
not particularly safer for fire engine
can't get there
thank you councilwale
I'm always the way there
carry on please sorry cancel the town
I believe it's a normal development of
the site I think if you took away the
the four the the eightfront units uh
we'll change the entire aspect of this
uh site and give more space for the
vehicles larger vehicles coming in and
going on but I think that's a very good
point raised about the fire engines at
Emergency Services I think you know they
have to be a serious consideration to
any industrial uh
site you know and that has really come
forward as far as we could see thank you
Council town and the right man not to
speak Council pull more
yes thank you chair to be very careful
what I say
um regarding that but um regarding
emergency vehicles there's no issue at
all
um having been an emergency fire plants
driving myself and still am there is no
issue but I have to be careful what I
say because I don't want to bring my
employment into this but from my
personal perspective there is no issue
with emergency vehicles thank you uh
thank you for that Council more
because of Garner
thank you I just wanted to ask a couple
of questions really this this
um application
as you say we we hope we um we viewed a
similar one on this site in December so
this is a brand new application no it's
not is it or not I'm from that no
I'm bringing I'll bring back uh yeah
it's not it's not in your application so
it's the same application what has
happened is we've received amended plans
which we've consulted on so that's why
it's being brought back in this manner
because we obviously consulted on some
amendments
is that why they may not necessarily
have been the same re-contact with
residents
um in the area and we we put enough of
the yellow signs and all that stuff yeah
but letters went out but no no new site
notice was posted
thank you
any other members
okay members I'm gonna put this to you
as you gather it is for uh for officers
approval
um those in favor with a please show
my hands
those against
abstentions
that has fallen I want to gain bear with
me please
members
um we're going to take a short
adjournment and it will be short I know
we have members of the public here with
us tonight
um could I ask a member
as we have done before to come up just
to have a word with their thoughts
um so we can put this to you
as what a surprise
no
uh thank you members
thank you members
Council towning
thank you
uh just for the sake of members
um what we've just done is obviously had
a few minutes to talk to officer himself
and the member
it has been said before what are we
talking about and everything else but it
is to resolve an issue we have because
as you know it's down for approval with
application it's been refused so we have
to come up with
something else and um
I believe that has been achieved so I'm
going to hand over to uh who's going to
propose a motion councilor Auburn yeah
thank you chair
um the motion of
propose is that this be deferred and
delegated back to offices to come up
with reasons for refusal
Isaiah finding it difficult at the
moment
and also whilst they're doing that is to
go back to the uh
applicant to try one more time to get
them to remove those
units that which we talked about if that
isn't the case either way it will come
back to the next planning meetings here
thank you councilman that's a proposal
could I have a second for that cancerous
shrub
members agree
a show of hands please
thank you those against
abstentions
one that has been carried thank you for
that members thank you again
okay moving on months gain to agenda
item 6 B which is the old Ford High
Street Garland Margate
speaking in favor of this application is
a Mr Jonathan buckwell over there Mr
buckwell you are you have three minutes
okay thank you good evening uh this
scheme is being proposed by Future homes
a local small developer based in fanet
who has an excellent track record in
providing good quality homes I would
like to just address a couple of the
concerns that have been raised by by
local residents firstly the access
members will note that the council has
previously approved four houses on this
site and whilst that was an outline
application the access is exactly the
same as that which is proposed tonight
and that was shown in detail previously
that was designed taking into account
advice from Kent County Council and as I
mentioned it was approved by this
Council
the bridal way meets the requirements of
Kent's public rights of way team traffic
movements here will be very limited and
at very low speed and I agree with the
planning officer that the proposals will
not make the bridal way unsafe for use
and other than a very short section at
the entrance less than five meters in
length for the bridal way will remain
separated from traffic in any event
um there's been no objection from either
KCC highways or the public rights of way
team
turning to the parking area opposite the
Old Forge this will be laid out in such
a way that there will only be two
parking spaces available which should
certainly help improve the access to the
driveway of number 158 we've listened to
the concerns that have been raised in
relation to waste collection and we've
amended the proposals to remove the
previously proposed structure most of
the time bins will be stored within The
Gardens of the proposed houses so that
the residents have easy access to them
and it's only on collection days that
bins will be taken to the presentation
Point opposite the Old Forge which is on
the current collection route
as you know the council lacks a
five-year Supply so the Tilted balance
applies planning permission as mentioned
has been previously granted for the same
size and scale of development on the
site with the same access arrangements
and as you'll have seen some of the
local residents whilst concerns have
been raised they some have said that
they are not opposed to the development
in principle and indeed some have
expressed support for certain aspects
such as removing the potential for over
parking opposite the Old Forge so in
light of this it's clear the adverse
impacts of the scheme do not
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
its benefits and therefore I hope you
can support these proposals tonight
thank you thank you very much Mr
buckwell uh speaking against the
application is Miss Natasha Hart
Miss hard please three minutes in
principle I've no major issue with the
opposed proposed four dwellings to the
rear of our next door neighbors property
though I do have many reservations about
squeezing that many in and the
subsequent overlooking however my main
concerns reflect those of the many
neighbors who have also opposed this
application regarding the multiple
negative impacts of this plan is
currently presented create please note
the two divorced sites we're discussing
in regards to this plant the rear Garden
area and the empty plot opposite the
current Old Forge are separated by a
public by the way used by pedestrians
horses cyclists and much local traffic
and there is a lot I live there I open
my front door to it I'd like to focus
the committee's attention to the pot
opposite currently used for parking and
proposed to be a Bim presentation area
along with two parking spaces firstly
and most significantly these bin spaces
if permitted will make it completely
impossible for waste collection to get
through no less than 18 properties
between High Street and birds Avenue
have their waste collected there luckily
the cars often park there in the evening
moved by the morning collection but
permanent store uh potential bin storage
and permanent parking will not secondly
us neighbors strongly feel that it's
unfair for this area to be used for the
waste of properties are not even inside
of it and they're hidden around the back
you'll see in the pictures who will
maintain this area who'll be left to
clear the debris a building yes would
have abstracted but still this will
these bin stores will inhibit the
potential visibility display and this
vast number of bins outside the front of
our house will actually be a worse
situation than a permanent building with
the obstruction that would have caused
it's highly unlikely that people only
bring their bins on that long journey on
collection day especially dragging their
bins out of a cul-de-sac and along a
seriously pothole Broadway the bins
wouldn't survive it and people just
won't bother they'll likely be left in
the presentation area and people will
drive or walk their bags out we strongly
feel the presentation area should be
allocated within the main plot of the
main dwelling adjacent to the assist in
property ensuring responsibility of the
waste area and organization within the
main dwelling plot we feel the reduction
of safety and sight lines of the
existing route for the wide range of
daily users which will only even more
with the turn fro traffic is absolutely
unacceptable the committee should
consider their responsibility here
carefully they're simply trying to
squeeze too much into this site with
limited access without consideration of
the residents I'd like to propose the
con the committee consider this solution
moving the bin store to with the patio
or Garden area of the old Ford and
reducing the two parking spaces out
front to just one allowing the continued
safe access and use by local residents
so they may have turning and parking
space when this new traffic arrives and
emergency services and the waste
collection route which has always been
may continue to service us all this is
something that will be a requirement of
a new property developer and is a small
sacrifice for the gift of the planning
permission for multiple dwellings most
potential objections objections could
potentially be retracted if these steps
were taken we'd also like you to
consider who'll be responsible for
repairing the impact all these
additional users will have on the
unadopted bride away a constant issue
for us living there will KCC be adopting
the new cul-de-sac and the Broadway
section there's access elements that
were mentioned were looked at in ice
relation that I don't think the bin
collection was looked at and adjacent to
the bride away adjacent to the traffic
going through the building that to me I
read with all separate reports and based
on that
um this planned situation is not as
simple as it may appear on a drawing
plan the split site's impact on 40 odd
plus neighbors and the access and safety
issues I explained need to be witnessed
in person to be understood I urge the
committee to please conduct a site visit
to see for themselves before making the
decision I'd also like to end with a
question if I may regarding the by the
way section
um is there not a rule regarding Public
Access routes that if they serve more
than a certain number of properties they
need separate parts for pedestrians
regarding the Broadway section from High
Street to the plotting the main dwelling
plot in question
thank you uh thank you you did well in
three minutes or just over missile
speaking as well counselor Council avoid
good evening everybody
um I don't normally appear at planning
so apologies if I look a bit Rusty
um I'd I'd like to thank um Miss Hart
um I have had several residents come
forward expressing their concerns about
the development
um obviously my concerns and
observations that have passed on are
reference in your agenda pack hopefully
you've had a chance to read it I know
you've had a a busy evening already
um I do have a lot of concerns around
the the public Bridal way which is the
link from the main roads to this site
um I drove in it to I say in it because
it's full of holes today just to double
check it because it's been raining today
um and my little course up less than uh
was really bumpy
um I would thoroughly recommend that a
site visit is undertaken because I think
when you look at Google Maps from a
satellite view you you really won't
understand the terrain that it is and
that it causes major issues we have a
lot of elderly people live around there
as well so again any more deterioration
will be a health and safety risk in
terms of Falls
um this site because it's so far away
from not so far away but it is from the
main roads
um and it is a small Bridal way as well
I do have concerns as to the The Works
traffic large vehicles coming in and out
it is a Broadway used by horses bikes
and people which obviously for their own
physical mental well-being I wonder if
any of those have actually been
consulted around it and actually been
pre-warned that that could be something
that they're facing
um I know that on page 133 years overall
is considered that any harm is
outweighed by the public benefits
however it is only four houses how much
of that is really a benefit
um in terms of the local area
um it also sites about the allowing
cards on the site to pass one another
and to be able to freely maneuver again
that might be fine on the site but
getting to the site is the actual
problem here
um so I would really recommend it be
deferred and go to a site visit and I'm
hoping that the plans that you see later
tonight will explain that a little bit
further thanks
uh thank you Council Boyd I'm going to
head over to planning officer which is
Annabelle to explain
the report
sorry thank you chair
so this is excuse me the two application
sites that have been referred to
outlined in Red so this is the Old Forge
here with the larger Garden area which
is where the dwellings would be located
and this is the red line area which
would be the car parking for the Old
Forge and the bin presentation area
um so you can see the High Street here
and this is the access that we're
referring to and then you go off down
towards the bridal way that's been
referred to
so this is an aerial view of the site so
you have you can see the two distinct
redlined areas here
again
so looking at this in more detail and
I'll look at some photographs in a
moment with to Show members so this is
the Old Forge this is 158 High Street
and this is the application site here
and this area here
so members might want to have a quick
look at some of the
elements so you can see in this aerial
view for example this element here of
the Old Forge which is the area that
part of the building that will be
demolished as part of The Proposal
this is a rear extension to the
adjoining property and just to give you
some bearings and we look at photographs
within the garden
this is a little blue outbuilding within
the current Garden
so this is the access road here
that comes into the site and you can see
a bit of the Old Forge
to the rear of that photo
another view of it and you can see the
side bit here and this is the Old Forge
and this side element here that would be
demolished as part of the proposed
proposal to create the access way
this is the um the sort of smaller red
lined area that we've seen so it would
be car parking for two cars in this
location and the bin presentation area
so this is looking at the Old Forge much
closer up you can see the edge of that
blue car we saw in the previous
photograph so that this would be the
parking and Bin presentation area to
here
and this is the Old Forge and this is
the element here to the side that would
be demolished
so again looking at this so I'm now
going to take you into the garden of the
Old Forge the main sort of bit where the
dwellings are proposed
so this is looking you can see just the
little blue building there so we're
looking down back towards the Old Forge
and the neighboring property there
this is looking
to the corner of the application site to
the rear of the boundary
and again enough of you you can see the
blue building we just mentioned earlier
and the upper corner of the application
site in the rear Garden
and I'm now going to take you outside
the sites we're going to have quick look
at
the bridal way and just some look around
these areas here
so this is the bridal way and the field
to join in sight
and this is again the the edge of the
Old Forge number 158
the blue car that we've seen in previous
photographs and the access
um as it wraps around this is the um
flank wall of number 158 and this is the
axis road and these properties these
properties and several offers front
Birds haven't you
so this is the existing site layout so
we've talked about the two red lines and
the Old Forge is sitting here with its
garden and that's the parking area
that's currently used for by the Old
Forge and this is a proposed um layout
so two parking spaces for the Old Forge
within this smaller red line and the bin
presentation area
the Old Forge with its side
extension removed the new access track
um four new dwellings
and two additional visitor spaces and
all of the dwellings are served by
private garden areas and at least and
two vehicle spaces and there is a garden
area retained for the Old Forge in this
location
so this is the old Ford the front
elevation
and this is the side elevation we'll see
in future future plans that will be
demolished
this is the rear elevations this
conservatory and the bit above it will
go so self elevation as existing and the
north elevation has existing of the Old
Forge so this is the current ground
floor plan of the old Force so it's this
area here that
um the application will demolish
and this is the first floor is existing
so this is the front elevation of the
old four Jazz proposed so this area here
as you can see dotted
um yes you can just see it will be the
area demolished so this is the
self-facing elevation again as proposed
the area dotted demolished
and the north facing elevation where you
can see the conservatory is also gone
and in the rear-facing elevations that
whole area
and dotted and in sort of yellow is gone
these are the floor plans proposed of
the
um
old Ford so you still that's the area of
demolished so their Lounge area and the
conservatory but it still is a good
sized family unit and it still retains
three bedrooms at first floor level
so looking again at this I'll take you
through into the sort of the site and
we'll look at the individual units and
we'll start with plot one plot one as
you can see faces onto the access road
it has its rear Garden
um facing on to
uh The Garden of the old sorry Forge
Cottage 158.
so looking at the ground floor plan
that's facing onto the axis road so it's
got a open plan dining kitchen area a
lounge and utility in WC
and at um first floor level it's a three
bedroom property as they all are
with a bathroom and Landing
that's the front elevation of the
property so as I say facing onto the
access road and this is the rear
um north-facing elevation that will look
towards the garden of number 158
you will note that that this property
actually sits
the closest point of the plot one sits
some 19 meters away from the rear flank
wall of the number 158.
and it has two windows here in the rear
elevation which serve
an ensuite and a bathroom and they will
be obscure glazed to prevent you any
overlooking this window here is a
bedroom window and that will be um
clear glaze to allow natural light and
ventilation to serve the
the bedroom in the future occupiers
but it is some
26 so yes 26 meters from the rear
of the the rear flank wall of 158 and it
is noted that the rear Garden of 158 is
actually overlooked by windows in
properties on birds Avenue in similar
locations so it's not considered that on
balance there would be harm
to the residential amenities of the
occupiers of number 158 from overlooking
from this property and it is set back in
from the boundary by the six meter
Garden that it it serves this property
so there's the the two flank elevations
of that property which you can see I
have no windows
so I'm now going to look at the
properties where they run this way two
three and four
so units two and four are identical so
they have the same elevations and
floor plans stay front on to that sort
of turning head that we've just looked
at so that's the front elevation sorry
the rear elevation there
and the self-facing elevations of plots
two and four and the north facing
again this is the ground floor so they
are identical it's a similar layout as
we've seen actually in unit one open
plan kitchen but it runs into the lounge
here but WC and utility as well here and
again a three-bedroom property
and now we're just going to have a look
at plot 3 which is slightly different as
it's handed to plots two and four
essentially
so that's the front of that unit
the rear of that unit the two sides
and again it's the handed design of
plots two and four essentially so that's
the ground floor
excuse me and a slightly different
um layout of the top floor but it is
still a three bedroom unit
so we have the bin presentation area and
as has been mentioned it is anticipated
well it is meant that bins will be
brought up on collection day only
and that they will be taken back down
into the storage areas Within
the residential plots and
it's and there would be parking for the
Old Forge in that location we've seen
where there was current parking now
um
so essentially we're looking at four
units that have been previously approved
albeit on an outline approval utilizing
the access that we're looking at here
it is not considered there will be any
harm or
congestion or narrow or impact on the
bridal way that runs along here
there would be adequate space for the
four units on the site they will be
served as I say by um private Garden
space and to parking it and a amenity
area reserved for the Old Forge itself
it is not considered there will be an
adverse impact on the residential
amenities or surrounding occupiers
and we have received a unilateral
undertaking for the Sam required Sam
contribution
so the recommendation is to approve the
application we do have some sweatpaths
as well that have been provided as
issues have been mentioned about
potential for the bin presentation area
particularly
to potentially cause problems
with access around into
past
158 and further all into the rear of the
road properties that front
Birds Avenue and as you can see here it
is possible
to progress and park and at the bin
storage presentation area does not
impact or harm that so the officer
recommendation is for approval
thank you Annabelle I moved the
officer's recommendation as you hear is
for approval with Vice chair please
second
I'll second nurture I think it cancer
every
Ingenuity of the bin store proposal but
I don't think it's remotely credible
I don't I don't really I don't really
imagine that people are going to take
their bins out there and only use that
bin store once a week and I I struggle
to see them taking them back and forth
at all
um I don't um
I'd like to ask what the amenity space
of unit 3 is because I I couldn't quite
work out where the where the garden
areas were on that plan and what the
size of that is
um and I don't really understand the
point that's been made about
um the use of the the bridal way uh and
this deterioration by vehicles in
relation to this development so I I have
to say and I don't very often say this
um I'm probably quite in favor of a site
visit but I hear what other members have
got to say thank you thank you Council
Robert so do you want to come back on
that Annabelle
can the garden areas for Block one sorry
there's Gardner of the Old Forge in this
location here that's retained plot one
as I say faces onto the access road so
its Garden area is in this location here
plots that plot four sorry that yes that
is plot four sort of it's Garden area
wraps around and plots to plot freeze
Garden is here
in this location and plot four in this
location I don't know the start the
measurements of the plots for the
amenity area offhand but I could measure
it if you were particularly interested
we don't have a an actual size
restriction or limit for garden spaces
but they do look adequate to serve a
family dwelling
uh thank you any other members wish to
speak okay councilor wing
dweep personality than Alice did it
involve waste vehicle-sized Vehicles
because obviously they've got to collect
the bins
and is there any separation physical
separation between the unadopted access
road and I have experience of those at
the back of my property and the bridal
path because that would be a concern
because if there isn't any separation
then where does one start and one begin
uh they're two two questions please
taking the second one first there is an
actual fence going to be proposed and
that is conditioned for details of that
to come forward along the edge of the
access road to separate it from the
bridal way
so that will be that and sorry I've gone
it was the vehicle sweep analysis did it
involve waste vehicle size vehicles
um well it has been brought to our
attention that the Refuge is actually
collected by a smaller vehicle already
that uses the site and that it did
account for that smaller size vehicle
it's not the big 13
um normal vehicle that you see it comes
around in and uses these roads so it's a
smaller vehicle currently and yes that
would be able to be accommodated
thank you Council grindin
thank you oh sorry sorry we're
forgettings counselor Auburn again a few
times he's invisible tonight have I
missed him again yes
um
uh I'm I'm agreeing uh with councilor
Everett here
um I I am a little confused about the
um the pothold road and quite the impact
of it and uh unless that can somehow be
clarified for me here
um I think a site visit May well be
um of considerable benefit thank you
it's not deliberate councilman I can
assure you
that's all right chair
I can live with it
um I'll check out about the what council
River says about the uh about the
triangle of land uh I mean it's Bonkers
in it you know to
so I mean if I lived in one of those
houses down I bought me think I'm
dragging my my being all the way out
there you've got another another thing
coming and I don't think anybody would
want to
um
yeah
well whatever you know especially when
it's hot as well we don't want to drag
all your bin up there would you but um
the development in itself the houses all
of that it's a good development a good
whether you could refuse it on the
grounds of the of the where the binge
store is I have extreme doubt about that
um but it's I mean you'd know if you
moved there that that's where you've
been stories so um uh
again I'm reluctant but I would yeah I'd
welcome a site visit chair
thank you Council Auburn I was going to
say that you're not as young as you used
to be but oh no that's quite true if I
if I could if if we're going for a
Cypress each year we're not going to go
buy a whole standard right away are we
I can't say well Council of Ghana
thank you yeah can you just show that
that
um swept
path analysis again I just wanted to
clarify one thing
[Music]
sorry yeah
yeah I thought so so it
it's dependent on one of those car
parking spaces for the Old Forge being
empty isn't it
so on bin day the Old Forge will have to
be knocked up to move their car if
they're parked there
thank you
any other members wish to speak Council
bayford
thank you just to say that I do agree
with other members I think it's it's a
fine development but I do think that the
bin arrangement
is not particularly
um
Bible thank you thank you Council Paul
Moore yes thank you
um I think one of the reasons they've
put that bin storage collection Point
there's because it's an unadopted Road
and I don't think the waste collection
team will go down there to pick up those
bins so it's down the owners for the
residents to take their bins to the
collection point so that they can be
emptied
um and again the issues will be there
depending on what they put down as the
access road be it gravel or whatever
will make things even worse and I agree
unfortunately with my colleagues on the
other side there that
um I don't think it's a viable thing to
be doing and I think a site visit would
be important because of the access to
the bridal way and so I'd be in favor of
a site visit as well but I think the
reason the bin collection point is there
is because it's unadopted and the waste
collection team don't have permissions
or to go down there and pick it from the
house so it would have to be brought to
the end of the road and that's why it's
there
um but I I think that that's the gray
areas thank you I think councilor Moore
any other speakers I don't see any other
speakers uh
Council Robin Joy just a question chair
um if I could ask Mr Livingston
um
providing the binge storage area is what
is required and we've required out on
any development such like that
would it not be very unusual to refuse a
planning application on the grounds that
there has been storage but it's not in
the right place
yes
[Laughter]
I think that just started to be a bit
flipping there the um I think it is it's
that
it's it is as customer points out it's
about low having to locate the bin
storage so that it's used by the refuse
team that come down that road at the
moment so there is a there is a
challenge here in terms of what is a an
interview an acceptable site of Housing
Development and indeed outline approval
being granted but how the bin storage
Works
um obviously
you could look at it individuals as you
say may may not bring the bin back every
single time but also obviously to
actually put waste out you would have to
go and take your waste to your bin which
is obviously down the the driveway so
um there are bin storage areas obviously
within each private residential property
as well because obviously that's where
you would take your bin out you know
every odd day or whatever it is
um but indeed it is it is something on
its own that that certainly you know if
you wouldn't substantiate a reason for
refusal it's something that could
potentially be looked at if members were
minded for a site visit to be discussed
again
hearing the debate and seeing what
options there are available if if any to
to change the proposal yep thank you Ian
uh Council grinding one thought that did
occur to me was can we move the parking
for the Old Forge to somewhere else and
just leave the wind's door there
I thought councilor Garner
I just wanted to check something the
outline permission has been mentioned a
couple of times I mean that was
2018 was granted wasn't it so how live
is that outline permission yeah come
back it's not so it's not extant you
have to put Reserve matters in within
three years the outline coming in and it
wasn't put in
um I think that the importance of the
outline is more in the sense of
obviously the principle of housing on
the site so that the the local plan
framework whilst it's changed obviously
we've got a 2020 local plan
um with the various changes the site is
even more acceptable for housing
effectively by virtue of a combination
of this being within the urban confines
now uh it's surrounded by the Strategic
allocation it's not within it just to be
clear but in the but the Westgate and
Garland strategic allocation
um so it's it's it's not an extant
permission at the moment though
like it comes forever well just going
back to Council of Garner's Point surely
the swept path analysis is useless if it
involves if it involves traveling over a
parking space which may well be occupied
when it's required yeah
yeah just to come back on that point
Vehicles aren't required necessarily the
swept path analysis
the the the actual refuse vehicle isn't
expected to turn around in this area it
would come out one end and go out the
other end of birds Avenue so yes it's
been shown again that turning could
happen if there was no vehicle there but
it's not an expectation that that
turning is needed for the refuse vehicle
it's private primarily that is to show
that actually you can get the refuse
vehicle round where the bins
presentation area is around the access
point because obviously there was some
concern that was raised about if you've
got bins there can you actually just get
a vehicle Round the Corner not
necessarily about turning around
uh thank you I'm going to stop debate
there put this to you it is uh
the application is for approval but I am
listening to what obviously for what's
been said so those in favor of approval
could they please show
those against
right I need a proposal now
I thought you might cancel Auburn
site if it's a second a please councilor
Beaufort several so those agree site
visit
31st of March
9 30.
me sorry uh
thank you members
item six C land rear of I'm 20 to 22
Westfield Road birchington
I have a couple of speakers here
speaking against this application is
councilor Hudson who I believe studies
the chairman of correct me if I'm wrong
with cancer I've put lurchington Parish
Council
thank you chairman
um
a couple of things on the report before
you firstly
um
Westfield Road is not in Westgate
which it says in a paragraph in the
report is actually in birchington
um and the the effect of this
development will have little or no
effect on the neighboring Cottages in
Westfield Road apart from the fact that
if if people want to go in by parking
their cars outside 20 or 22 Westfield
Road there are parking restrictions and
it's unlikely because it's virtually a
cul-de-sac that they'd be able to park
there for any length of time
the main objections come from the the
rear of the site which comes onto oxney
Close
now Oxnard close is one of three closest
that were were put in when that the
gardens estate was first developed and I
know it was some 60 or 70 years ago but
they each of those closes at the end of
them have an Alleyway or or footpath
that allows people to get into the town
and and they are very very well used the
estate was pretty much originally built
for retirees and that's the sort of a
people that are there at the moment and
they do their shopping by going up the
passageway so in Oxnard closed six six
bungalows
um
Road narrow
very narrow is acknowledged in the
report it is narrow
um if waste Vehicles go up and down the
road which they do
um there's no room for them for any
other traffic on the road it is hopeless
um and it is Westfield Road uh sorry
Oxley close that is really affected
there is no real turning circle at the
end of the of the close and the Oxnard
close has got traffic restrictions on
both sides of the roads
so
that is a major problem
it's a major problem for construction of
the site
uh
building Vehicles we know they're quite
large they're quite difficult
um and they wouldn't be able to get up
there
um easily to work on the site
the
effect
on people within the near area with
mobility issues I've already mentioned
that they use the footpath to go up into
the town that is difficult and there are
a lot of mobility scooters and that used
in birchington
other concern that residents have is
that we the Public Services
Mains Water waste water
etc etc because of the design of the
clothes that is a worry worried about
Emergency Services getting up there the
same the same objections with the waste
vehicles
um they're interested to know if people
have actually visited the site and
understand
um
what what the situation is
I I think they're that's probably the
points are made by the by the residents
and it is a great concern to them
believe me
um I understand that um
if planned permission is granted for
development it has to be capable of
being implemented officers will advise
on that but given the restraints on the
site
um I wonder if it could be implemented
if they can't deliver building materials
to the site and they obey the road
traffic conditions which I also see in
the report that somebody else's problem
and I understand that's easy to say
that's somebody else's problem
um but I'm sure most members will
understand
that environmental considerations for
planning
and parking is very difficult to control
certainly out in the Villages it is so
we're worried about that I counselor I'm
nearly absent all right if you
that's quite unusual I know if you do
pursue this
um I do believe construction management
plans need to be submitted to know how
they are going to develop the site I'm
totally opposed to the site many of my
colleagues are as well thank you
chairman thank you for your patience
Amanda no thank you councilor Hudson uh
speaking under Council procedure 20.1 is
counselor fellows
thank you chair thank you members I
might duplicate a few things that
councilor Hudson said but I'll say them
again anyway I've spoken a number of
times at this committee sometimes for
sometimes against but this application
really is the most opportunistic
profiteering that I've come across in my
in my opinion so I'm surprised it's up
for approval this evening I believe the
applicant owns both 22 and 20 to 20 and
22 Westfield Road and now wants to take
a slice off each of the small back
Gardens from each property and build
another house uh the Westfield Road
address is very misleading as the
property proposed will actually be in
oxney close oxen close is a very small
cul-de-sac off Kent Gardens consisting
of a few small Bungalows it's very
narrow single file road with yellow line
restricted Park and there's no daytime
parking there at all most residents use
oxy close as a cut through between the
gardens estate where a lot of our Elder
residents live as a pedestrian right of
way to the village and I think there's
some concerns about the closure of the
right of wage during the construction of
the building to build another house in
Oxford close will lead to a very cramped
feel to an already small quiet close
there's been numerous objections to the
planning application there's quite a few
on the website I'm sure members have
seen them all the objections include
over development too close to adjoining
properties inadequate parking provision
not complying with the local plan
development is in the Turning area for
Oxley close removal of trees lots of
privacy lack of concern by the applicant
on on neighbors surface water runoff
after building on the back Gardens an
unsympathetic design to name a few Mr
chairman I've always been opposed to
Garden developments of any type and this
one is no different I'm going to ask my
colleagues here this evening to refuse
permission for this application um it's
either field they can't refuse then I
please I asked for members to go and
have a site visit and have a look for
themselves to see what the issues are
there thank you
thank you Council fellows uh asked the
officer which is Emma to give the report
please
[Music]
this
this is the application site outlined in
red here so um the area outlined in blue
is numbers 20 and 22 Westfield Road so
Westfield Road is at the top of this
slide and then oxney close which is a
cul-de-sac is located here below the
site and then the application is for the
Redevelopment of this area here at the
end of the cul-de-sac
so this is just an aerial view of the
site so you can see there's The Gardens
of numbers 20 and 22 in this location
here there's an existing garage within
the rear of this property which would be
demolished in order to make way for the
proposed dwelling and you can see in
terms of the actual Street
um the the existing Bungalows you can
see there are pairs of semi-detached and
detached Bungalows and within this small
cul-de-sac area
and this is the application site here so
this garage Falls within one of the
gardens within the application site and
then the area extends off to the left
here so it covers this area behind
um this this brown fence area here so
it's both of these Gardens being
developed for
um a single dwell in
and then a further view back so you see
on the left hand side here this is a
five Oxley close
and then a further view here again so
again the application site is this area
here this garden and this Garden
and then again a further view this is
now over to number six Oxley close again
you can see both of them both the
neighboring properties are existing
Bungalows this garage Falls within the
rear Garden of
um number 24 Westfield Road so this this
doesn't fall within the application site
and the public right away that was
referred to is in this location here and
to the right of number 24.
then this view is looking back towards
the um the other end of the cul-de-sac
so the application site is behind us
looking towards
um The Junction here and again you can
see the the
um single story nature of the the
dwellings in the road
and then this view is just taken from
the other end looking back towards the
application sites the application sites
in this location here to the rear of the
semi-detached properties
and then another view here so um these
are the properties that front onto
Westfield Road so these are numbers 20
and 22 so the existing properties
um in which the um the drain will be
built within the Garden area and again
here so what's useful to see within this
these photos is just the fact that they
have existing um parking areas to the
front of those properties off Westfield
Road so whilst there's a garage located
at the rear of one of the gardens that's
not the only parking area serving these
units that the parking's actually
located to the front of the units as
well from Westfield
and so this is the existing plan showing
the existing site so you can see they're
currently um two long Gardens there's
the garage is located in this area here
and you can also see the public
right-of-way in this location here
you can see that within oxney close
there's a small turning head
um which would not be suitable for
larger Refuge vehicles but would be
suitable for for smaller cars and and
delivery lorries this area has not been
touched through the applications the
application solely is for the area
within the Garden area would not um
change the nature of that turning head
so this is the proposed plan so you can
see here the hatched area is the outline
of the footprint of the proposed
dwelling so it's an an L-shaped dreading
the original plan that came in did
extend the derailling further with a
carport in this location here but this
plan has been amended to remove the
carpool area in order to increase um the
space and Garden area around the unit
and it's a closer view of the block plan
so again you can see the footprint of
the unit in this location here this area
to the front would provide parking for
two vehicles off-site so they'd both be
able to both
um Vehicles be as park off the site not
in in not disturbing the turning head
and then this area here would be the
garden to serve the unit which is a two
bed unit therefore requiring doorstep
play Space so this area here would be
enclosed with a 1.8 meter fence
then this is a elevation view of the
proposed Bungalow so um it's quite
um a shallow roof
um in terms of the height of the
building it's 2.4 meters up to ease
level which is the height of the
existing garage on the site so the only
addition is the actual pitch roof above
in terms of height level and at the
highest point it reaches four meters the
lower area here is
um
3.4 meters
um you can see it's a a brick and tiles
for the unit and this area here on the
left is set back so there's just a main
projecting Gable to the front here
and this is the rear elevation with
obscure glaze Windows looking back
towards the pair of semi-attached
weddings
um so there's no concerns with any
overlooking given the obscure-gazed
nature of these windows
and then this is the side view so Oxley
road is on the right hand side here and
you can see and part of one of the
neighboring properties you can see the
setback from the road and again the
shallow form of the unit
and then this is the other view so again
Oxley Road nose on the left hand side
and you can see the um the side Aviation
of the proposia unit here
so this is a floor plan just showing the
unit so it's a two bed unit so two
bedrooms and the bathroom area here and
a large open plan Lounge kitchen area
and to the front of the site and again
you can see more detail the two parking
spaces the front and the Garden on the
left hand side here
and then the reef plan
and then this is just a sections showing
and the exist existing situation to the
top so
um I think this glass house is actually
in a neighboring property so but what
this is showing is the current distance
from the existing so many touch
properties to the nearest neighbor in
Oxnard close on the left and then the
bottom view is showing the height of the
proposed unit in relation to the
neighbor so you can see it's a lower
property than the existing properties in
Oxen close it's a very modest size
building and you can see the distance
between the proposed unit and the
semi-detached units back in um Westfield
Road
so um the main considerations are
um the impact on the character imperency
area and living conditions and Highway
Safety so I'll just go back to
the proposed layout in terms of the site
it's a rear Garden area it's within the
urban confines so there's no principal
objection to the development of the site
for a single dreading and subject to the
impact on the character appearance of
the area and other material
considerations being acceptable in terms
of the character appearance of the area
as you can see it's a cul-de-sac
um that consists of semi-detached and
detached
Bungalows this is a proposed Bungalow
it's um it's a modest size unit it's at
the head of the cul-de-sac it would fit
in with the existing
um character of the air with the
existing pattern of development so
there's no significant concerns
regarding the impact of this on the
visual communities of the area and the
units set back from the road so there's
a front issue again similar in character
to the other neighboring properties and
and there's space maintained around the
unit with the side Garden area and which
means it's considered to be an adequate
sized plot to fit a single unit upon in
terms of the impact upon neighbors
um the distance to the neighbors in
Oxley close as 11.5 meters to number
five and 11 meters to number six which
is in the bottom of the slide here and
both these distances give again given
the fact it's single store in nature is
not considered to impact on any lighter
Outlet to those properties in terms of
the impact to the properties in
Westfield there's a distance of 9.4
meters
to the closest point of the neighbor
property and you can see on the plan
here those are oh sorry
um that they maintain a garden of at
least 10 meters in depth to the rear of
their properties which is considered
acceptable in terms of that Garden size
for those properties and in terms of
again that distance to the impact on on
their Windows there's no overlooking
given the fact it's it's only single
story and the rear windows would be a
skew glaze looking back towards the
neighbors
um so the impact on on living conditions
is acceptable and it meets the space
standards and and achieves a doorstep
play space that's required by policy in
terms of the actual impacts on highway
safety
um the the site has two off street
parking spaces which is considered
appropriate and there's access to it and
there would be adequate visibility from
those spaces into the road
um the the turning head is being
maintained and whilst it is appreciated
that there would potentially be some
concern from construction traffic it is
usually standard that we would put on a
construction management plan condition
onto a consent so if members were
concerned with that we could add that on
as a condition requiring um details of
the constructions coming through that
plan and that could also look at the
public right-of-way and how the actual
access for that is maintained during
construction so something that could be
added and we could seek details on
um but otherwise it's not considered
there would be any significant harm to
highway safety from this additional
dwelling and the parking appropriate and
there's additional cycle parking
provided within the site as well so it
is recommended to be deferred and
delegated subject to the legal agreement
to come in for the SBA contribution to
be secured and subject to safeguarding
conditions thank you uh thank you very
much Emma I move the office's
recommendation Vice chair please second
a second nature thank you Council common
cook Council Everett
yeah I've got to say I don't see a lot
wrong with it to be honest with you I
think the fact that there's already a
garage access onto Oxley close is is
quite persuasive of the suitability of
the vehicle access on talks because I
can't see the difference between a car
coming out of one garage which you could
potentially do at the moment and two
parking spaces is of any substance
um I do think that it will be a good
idea to add the extra condition that
Emma's referred to I'd like to propose
that but some subject to that I think
it's acceptable thank you thank you
cancer ever it uh
Casa Ghana
yeah I would just like a bit of
clarification about the car parking
spaces because I'm finding it difficult
to visualize
where exactly they would go a quick and
that's sort of also in relation to the
house or the Bungalow at the top left
there has a car that goes in and out of
a driveway right adjacent to the
proposed new garden and that would
obviously need to come all the way out
without being hindered by anything so
that it can turn around and I can't
quite see how two cars can you do you're
going to fit on the fit on there without
hindering it so if you could just sort
of explain that a bit a bit to me please
um so on the plan here you can see I
don't know if you can see actually it's
quite faint but there's
um a faint outline of two vehicles
within this front garden area here so
one is parked in this location here
where you can see the quite a deep area
of driveway and the other is a parallel
parking space in this location here
which is something that KCC are starting
to accept as appropriate and if there's
enough distance from the front
innovation of the property so for number
five they would still be able to turn
into their driveway in this like in in
this location here and then for
reversing out they'll be able to reverse
into the turning head and turn out and
this area shouldn't be obstructed
because there's adequate space within
the front here for the two vehicles to
park
um in these two locations without
overhanging the highway
thank you do I see any other hand it
comes up well yes thank you chair
unfortunately I'm not in favor of this
development because it is a rear Garden
development and to me it impacts
severely on oxy close
um they've tried to make it look as nice
as possible with the fact that you've
got a car driving in a car on the side I
can see nothing but problems there with
that and I wouldn't be for this approval
thank you thank you
any other hands
excuse me
just a little bit of advice from Mr
Livingston that you've seen that put a
motion to you it has been suggested
about
um the movement of traffic and so forth
from cancer Everett to be added to
report I would like to propose that and
I'll ask the vice chair 2 second
if you agree five seconds
uh I'm looking at members you heard
councilor every so I think it makes
sense as well so uh
those in favor of yep okay
yeah so just to confirm the motion that
was performed was to defer and Delegate
for approval as we talked about the
start of of the meeting the condition
that's that's been mentioned which will
be mentioned by Emma as well is a
construction management plan condition
um so this is a standard condition that
we've put on other applications so it
would be the recommendation is still to
defer and Delegate for approval subject
to securing the legal agreement and it's
got the safeguarding conditions in the
report at the moment but it would be to
add a construction management plan
condition as well
obviously members understand yep anybody
else wish to speak before I put this to
note
Council Wing uh thank you can I just
clarify so if we defer and delegate does
it come back here for us to have another
view okay thank you
okay members those in favor is defer and
delegate but please show
thank you those against
abstentions
that has been carried thank you members
writer members thank you uh moving on
again to agenda item 6D 75 cluster
Avenue in Margate
um speaking in favor of this application
is Mr Morgan Mr Morgan
if you're there okay please bear with me
I'm petrified
um
sort of the inconvenience to all right I
didn't think I needed planning
permission to erect these Gates as there
was always existing wall around my
property of two meters high my only
intention was to make it was dated so
basically Mr Morgan I'm sorry I'm
busting in can you move a little bit
closer to your mic okay so we'll move
the mic
thank you
carry on
start again
sorry for my sorry for the inconvenience
store but I was I can't just give up
I'm very sorry I've had nervous
breakdowns today because it is
I'm here today about these Gates yeah
my house is is 75 Gloucester avenue
um
I can't do it I'm sorry I can't do it
please please don't worry
whenever I tried to read it I sound like
a robot like I'm a painter decorator
this is not what I do please don't worry
this is that is fine um cancer fellows I
believe you're going to read this is not
go and read it read it for me
they send the bill okay thank you he's
saying sorry uh for the inconvenience to
all but I didn't think I would need
permission to erect these Gates as there
was already an existing wall around the
property at two meter high his only
intention was to improve the look of the
frontage by replacing the concrete block
wall connecting the garage to the
surrounding wall with Gates and by doing
so we could make better use of the front
garden
when I bought the property when he
bought property it was with the
understanding that we clearly need
modernization modernizations and the
gates were part of that investment he
did speak with his neighbors prior to
the change without any negative feedback
in fact they all said they would do the
same if it was there there's as the old
concrete and Pebble Dash was ugly they
were all so happy as it meant they could
use the whole front garden to park
rather than just the driveway
his partner and he both have a car and
also has a Works fan a classic car and a
boat which are now stored off-road
giving clear view of Princess walk and
the sea he's also arranged for the Bland
1990s Pebble Dash to be rendered and
painted to approve the appearance
brick wall opposite with its flaking
paint finally these Gates would provide
added security for our pet dog a border
a Bordeaux Mastiff from getting out or
fighting in any passes by by her size
once again he's sorry for the drama
correcting these Gates uh has caused
everyone but he does hope that you will
accept this change hasn't added negative
impact on the Aesthetics or character of
the road and area
as I think counts for is such a well
done
and don't worry Mr Morgan he gets to Us
hall and I'm going to assure you uh
okay I'm gonna ask
I'm gonna ask Emma to give the report
please thank you Emma
thank you uh this is the
disease Gloucester Avenue and Palm Bay
Avenue to the top of this slide
and these are the gates so it's a
retrospective application
um it's for the gates that are 1.8
meters in height
um you can see in terms of the design
that the include solid panels and they
have a dark colored finish
um
and this is the view further down the
road so you can see this is the existing
side elevation so these are the um this
is the walls that um the applicants
refer to as having recently been
rendered
and then this is the neighboring
property with their wall which again the
both of these are have historically been
in situ so these haven't there's no
evidence of any planning permissions for
these but they've been there for a long
time
um looking back on the history so these
are lawful walls now in terms of this
height
and this is the view down gross Avenue
so you can see in terms of our concerns
the area is
um very open all the property is very
open with very low boundary rules to the
front of the site and you can see very
very open in terms of the character and
so the concern would be any High
boundary walls to the front of the
properties would appear out of keeping
this open character of the area
this is looking back towards Palm Bay
Avenue so you can see there is some
evidence of high boundary walls at the
end of this road but these area these
walls um tend to contain the actual
private rear garden areas of or side
garden areas of the properties and
aren't generally
um consistent with the front boundary
treatments properties so you can see
again here that on the corner there's a
property that has a low wall and then
the air the rail is above are quite open
so it allows you to still get a sense of
of looking into the site and feeling
like a sense of openness rather than
being very enclosed
so the gates are in this location here
on the front um of the site on the
left-hand side of the site and again
these are the now the details of it
which you saw in the photos
and there's a pedestrian grate on the
right hand side and then a vehicle the
gate on the left
and then again a view of that so this
application has um previously been
submitted and refused
um the ground's been to do with the
height design and location of the gates
creating a stock and highly prominent
feature which is in congress with the
open character of the surrounding area
so this application is a resubmission
there's no change in the um the actual
details have been submitted so it's
therefore recommended for refusal again
on those same grounds
um I'll just show you a view of
um how the site was previously so this
is a historic Google image that we have
found of how the site looked prior to
the gates being erected and the wall
being rendered and so you can see this
area was open there was no gates in this
location and you could sort of get a
sense of openness looking into the site
so whilst the actual wall itself is is
quite high this area maintained openness
in keeping with the area so the concern
is that the gates now enclose that and
create a fully solid Frontage
um that does detract from the area so
it's recommended for refusal thank you
uh thank you Emma I recommend the
officers recommendation which you've
heard is refusal the vice chair please
second oh second nature thank you
Council Coleman cook a few hands going
up counter
blank
um
I am the ward coaster for this area
the the gates actually provide for this
family
privacy security
not just for themselves but they have
some very
special dogs
I had lots of long ago unfortunately for
that they uh
they lost a dog because he got out of
the house that unfortunately was uh they
lost
what we're going to remember is that
there's not a single
of resident of Labor that has actually
objected to this particular uh these
particular Gates
the if you if you look uh at that size
at that street uh uh Gloucester Avenue
and if you go up towards north down Road
I mean the the view we saw down the
street was towards the sea but if we go
the other way you will find that there
are fences much higher than that they're
different different Gates along that
street
so you know there's nothing about those
Gates that are unappealing there's
nothing about the games that are unusual
um in fact it helps the property to give
it give them a Pit Boss or privacy to
the home
um
as far as uh the uh the parking issue
goes they their pocket they they their
their cars are off the street so it's
not not adding to any street parking so
it's it's in general terms it's it's a
it's a
it's a benefit to everyone living around
that house so I would ask my colleagues
over here to refuse the uh proposal by
the officers and com and approve the
application to to leave the gates where
they are thank you thank you Council
towning Council roses
thank you chair uh I'm inclined actually
looking at the pictures and looking at
the pictures of the walls beforehand and
everything to agree with councilor
towning here and so that actually Gates
don't look that bad they're only 1.8
meters it gives the house of security it
requires Everyone's entitled to a bit of
security nowadays and I don't see any
problem with it I'll be uh looking to um
again go against the officer's
recommendation
thank you councilor Alton
yes thank you chair I went down and had
a look at it uh this afternoon and as
Constantin has said uh when you come
down North North
Gloucester Avenue from North down road
on the left-hand side there's a
monstrosity of a wooden wooden fence
which comes out comes along goes back in
comes along comes back out castleated
it's a monstrosity whether that's got
planning consent or not I do not I do
not know but having come down here and
and had a look at that it has no impact
whatsoever on on the local amenity of
the area and I certainly can't agree
with them with the officer's
recommendation thank you chair thank you
Council Auburn can't support more yes
thank you chair
um having looked at both the picture
prior and existing now
what the occupant has done has made that
a striking building and improved the
quality of it and I see no reason why he
can't have that gate so I will be voting
against the officer's recommendation
thank you any other members wish to
speak
a cancer shop there's another herbal
counselor I had to look around there
today uh when the other day uh no you
wouldn't
and uh I tell you what that has been
that's an improvement on what was there
before going by the other pictures and I
will be going against the officer's
recommendation I think it counts just
Rob Council Robert
yeah I think the decisive factor for me
is the height of the existing wall
whether that whether that wall was ever
put up without planning consent in the
first place the fact that the walls
there and conceals a lot of the front of
the property in the first place makes it
much less
much less of a change than it would be
if the war wasn't there obviously I mean
I don't think we would want all the
properties along that road to wall
themselves in in that way but that isn't
what what's in front of us because that
certainly would change the character of
the area and I do have some sympathy
with the officers bringing it forward
for a refusal but I think on balance
because of the heart of the wall
um I think we probably have to let it go
thanks
thank God for everything that I don't
see any other hands um you've heard the
officer's recommendation which is
refusal those in favor of that please
show please raise your hand
those against offers recommendation
right that has been lost so bear with me
a moment please come back to Ian so it's
it's quite clear that that members
consider that the development wouldn't
harm the character appearance of the
area and obviously if members remember
wants to propose approval on the basis
that it doesn't harm the character
appearance the area
couldn't get his hand up quick enough
there uh counselors
I recommend approval
on the ground so the fact that it is
there's nothing wrong with it and it's
it all fits in quite nicely
I know it's getting late also safety
because if their dogs get out again all
right thank you
thank you
I'm not going to ask councilman to do
that dance he did just now with uh but
those in favor of that proposal
okay anyone against
no obviously that has been carried for
himself thank you
thank you members
your last item on this evening's agenda
is item 6 e which is number 60 to 68
High Street
one in Ramsgate and one to 11 George
Street ramscape on the corner and
speaking in favor of this application is
Mr Matthew garlic I hope I've said that
right
garlic uh no but it doesn't matter
everyone gets it wrong I beg your pardon
it so
you have three minutes thank you very
much
um
we would like to uh thank the planning
committee for this opportunity to speak
at the meeting
we're at JDP limited firstly wanted to
outline our current Redevelopment
proposals for Ramsgate this basically
focuses on the Redevelopment of existing
buildings located within the Town Center
these buildings are typically
dilapidated and are either suitable for
conversion or extension or in the
current case required Demolition and
Redevelopment of the site
JDP are already redeveloping another
site in Ramsgate and will hopefully
deliver 31 one and two bedroom
apartments at the former Sports Direct
site
as well as providing much needed
sustainable residential accommodation
the development will also provide more
sustainable commercial units which will
be aimed at the Independent Community
users
we would like to point out to the
committee that the decision for sports
direct to pull out of the site was
theirs alone
they like other large companies are
pulling out the High Street in their
droves JDP are already in discussions
with other smaller Independents about
renting a newly converted retail spaces
which is a real positive and hopefully
justification of the current model
we acknowledge that there have been
several negative comments made
pertaining to the scheme in our opinion
most of these comments require political
solution or response
however we have completely addressed all
of the matters necessary to demonstrate
policy compliance and consider our
proposals are completely in accordance
with the mppf and the local plan
requirements
we have in our opinion done our best
with this site and it will be and if it
was to be approved would deliver on much
needed sustainable and affordable
accommodation within the Town Center
it was true that no car parking
provision has been Incorporated within
the proposals the committee are reminded
that the site lies in a totally
sustainable position for public
transport but has also directly adjacent
to Meeting Street public car park and
also close to other underutilized car
parts located in Cannon Road Leopold
Street and Staffordshire Street
JDP are totally committed to Future
requirements of any current tenants that
have approached us expressing an
interest to remain at these or any other
premises within the JDP portfolio
JDP are proactively looking at options
available for pilgrims hospice
for this alternative sites similar
Arrangements would be offered to all
tenants if a formal approach were to be
received but we can categorically
confirm that this has not been the case
we hope that committee agrees with
officers and supports the degree
development of this site by approving
the current proposals thank you thank
you I'll try again Mr gerlack
thank you
speaking against the application under
Council procedure 20.1 is cancer Austin
thank you chair
um actually there's a great deal to to
like about this application uh the
design is a massive Improvement on what
we have at the moment and fits in much
better with the conservation area it
provides a variety of small shop units
which is one of the things we really
need having empty big box shops in the
Town Center where the owners won't
divide them into the small units that we
need it's providing housing it's a
Brownfield site in the town center it's
providing housing and it's providing the
sort of housing that we need which is
one and two bedroom Flats
there are all the Heritage provisions
and sustainability Provisions are all
excellent what I think is worrying Ward
councilors and is worrying local
residents is the number of flats it
appears to be considerably overdeveloped
39 Flats in this relatively small block
is a hell of a lot and by far the
majority of those are one bedroom flat
so there isn't doesn't appear to us be
much of a balance between different
types of accommodation it's 32 one
bedroom Flats five two bedroom two three
bedroom we feel that that is is
overcrowded we're looking at a lot a
very high density of a single person
accommodation or single bedroom Flats
um
the fact that there
are no affordable units in the building
is a real concern because Ramsgate is
not the best off Town in the world and
we really need accommodation for our
local residents so the the pricing
structure is is a worry
um I am no expert on viability
appraisals and whatever and in fact I'm
no expert on on planning at all but
actually the comparison flats that have
been chosen in the viability appraisal
look if you're in Surrey as the Praises
were very close but actually they're the
opposite side of town and um I would
have to say that they're in a
particularly exclusive area because they
happen to be at the top of my street but
they're certainly in a very different
sort of area they're not in a town
center location we're really worried
that there aren't any affordable units
in in this
um in this proposal
um Mr garlic has referred to the parking
issue and obviously we know that there's
no requirement for this to be part
talking but there are concerns that
there isn't any parking and although we
do have the very good loot bus system uh
in uh serving Ramsgate it doesn't really
serve that part of the Town Center so we
would be looking at people
um trying to to park in the relatively
limited car park spaces available and
finally it would have been lovely to see
the the
um the developers doing what they're
trying to do for example the sports
direct building and take an existing
building and do something with it rather
than knock the whole thing down and
start again not because the existing
building is beautiful and needs to be
preserved because it certainly doesn't
um but because of the embodied carbon
we're concerned about the um there's a
lot of sustainability work has gone into
this but there's a real concern about
the environmental implications of total
demolition let alone the Practical
implications of the disruption that it
will cause so in general we like the
idea that this is what's going to happen
but we have some serious concerns about
the the number of units the overcrowding
and some other issues thank you thank
you councilor Austin I'll ask Annabelle
I believe now over the planet officer to
outline her report yeah thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red
I'll zoom in here this is an easier plan
to see so this is the application site
here on the corner of the High Street
and George Street
just to give you some bearings
and this is Colette house which is a
block of flats and this is Meeting
Street in the meeting street car park
here and obviously the High Street
running along here
so just an aerial view of the site so
you can
easily see Meeting Street Car Park here
and this is the application site that
wraps around in this location here
some just some photographs of the site
it's this is looking down the High
Street you can see the site
here in this location
this is a viewer part of the site
as you can see it's a fairly modern sort
of 20th century building
um and this is number 70 High Street and
that is actually a listed building
so looking at the corner as it turns in
Shore Street and High Street we are
looking at a building that's in the
Ramsgate Conservation Area
and the Ramsgate Conservation Area
appraisal was actually adopted in March
22 2022
and it's identified as lying within
character area two which is the historic
commercial core and it's actually
identified in that um
appraisal as being an answer in
unsympathetic 20th century commercial
units
and identifies as an opportunity for
enhancement
so if we look at some more photographs
that's looking up George Street so you
can see it turning the corner here and
it drops down in height in that location
here so that's the bit where it drops
down and this is number 13 George Street
and this is looking back the other way
as you can see the lower bits here and
the bit where it turns the corner back
into the High Street
this is actually of the rear of the site
so you're looking at number 70 the
listed building here
and this is the site here and I'm
obviously taking it from The Meeting
Street Car Park
this is a closer view so you can see the
edge of the site here and number 70 and
you can see there's a rear extension to
that listed building here which is as we
understand it in residential use
and this is looking to the rear of
properties in George Street so this is
the application site in this location
here this is number 13 15 and 17 and you
can just see the edge of Colette house
which is the larger block of flats in
that location
so this is the existing High Street
elevations this is George Street going
off in this location here
so this is the existing
elevation you'll see from The High
Street this is the list of building
that's been talked about number 70 so
it's free stories alsoever mansard roof
here
and this is a proposed High Street
elevation so again George Street will be
sitting goes off here
and you can see you've got commercial
units on the ground floor here and
residential above going up into the
mansard roof
this is the existing draw Street
elevation so you're turning the corner
and that's number 13 George Street here
and this is a proposed
um
George Street elevation so it's
commercial as you turn the corner into
George Street that's the last commercial
unit and then it goes into residential
which is appropriate in George Street
because that's not within the uh the
town center but obviously the High
Street party is so you're keeping the
active uses at ground floor
in the High Street elevation and moving
to more residential even on the ground
floor as you turn into George Street
so this is the rear of the George Street
elevation so that's actually number 13
you can see there and that's the bit we
looked at in the photograph
and this is what's proposed so that's
number 13 here and again you can see the
units there
coming up
and this is the rear of the High Street
elevation so that's the photograph we
looked at taken from The Meeting Street
sort of car park that's number 70 with
its rear Edition here
and this would be
um
excuse me the proposed elevation to the
rear of the High Street so you can see
the mansard roof
and again the relationship with number
70 there so there is the gap between the
ruse there
and so this is the existing ground floor
plan so you can see number 13 George
Street there number 70. and as we've
seen it's a variety of
um commercial uses that sort of wrap
around currently there and that's the
existing first floor plan and you can
see there's that area where it drops
down so that's flat roofed
and so this is proposed ground floor
plan so you've got the four commercial
units that front the High Street in this
location here
then you have the fifth commercial unit
in this location here
and then we have two flats that front
George Street in this location
uh another flat here
a cycle store
that serves the residential development
and a bin store that also serves
um
the actual residential development with
the commercial install each commercial
unit having their own bin stores
separately there is also an amenity
space here that again serves the
residential units and this is again a
bin presentation area so bins can be
transported on the day they're due to
the collection collected into that area
and then returned back into the bin
store
so looking at the floors as we go up it
is a series of residential units
set against
around as I say and now we're looking at
all residential above on these floors
it's a similar pattern on the second
floor
and again we're now in the mansard roof
we have accommodation in that area as
well
and that's the proposed actual roof plan
so just to give you some idea of some
Heights of the building it there's the
section as existing so that's actually
from The High Street so you can see
number 70 there
with its mansard roof and that's the
sort of scale of building you're looking
at currently
um this was the proposed section so you
can see how the floors
um come into play so you'd have the
commercial units on the ground floor
here
the two
residential floors and then the mansard
roof there and you can see it is a
similar height
um two number 70. and it gives more of a
presence in officer's opinion as it
turns the corner
and so you're looking at the rear
elevation it's existing to the rear of
um George Street so that's number 13
again
and this actually gives you a bit of a
close-up of the proposed rear elevation
again the same elevation looking onto it
with number 13. so you can see the
mansard roof this is the bin storage and
things that we looked at in the proposed
development
and again this is
the elevation of the front of George
Street so this is again number 13 and
this is the
bit that where it drops in height as it
wraps around the corner currently and
this is the proposed elevation
um with the mansard roof that you can
see here that the Gap is maintained
between the building as it turns the
corner and number 13.
and again this is the roof plan of that
we've of the area we just looked at so
number 13 here
the proposed roof plan sorry that's
existing we plan but you can see the Gap
there
and you can see here that this with the
mansard roof and the proposed
development that Gap is maintained and
it I don't know if members can see
there's an existing window here and
there's the 45 degree line just to show
that there would be no overlooking from
that
this is the existing elevation at the
front the High Street and you can see
that's the listed building and there is
condition
um obviously the building is attached to
um the list of building and so officers
have requested a condition which has
been agreed by the applicants
for a method statement as to how that
building will be demolished and
constructed to avoid any adverse impact
on that list of building and that would
be the proposed front innovation
so you can see as previously noted it is
similar in height and has similar
proportions of a larger ground floor and
the you know the hierarchy of Windows
getting smaller as the building Rises up
and that's the existing roof plan so
this is number 70 here and the proposed
sorry the existing we plan on number 60
to 68 or the end of 68. and again this
is the proposery plan and you can see
again the windows here at the red sort
of outlines and the 45 degree lines and
that's the window that you'd have seen
at the end of that rear extension on
number 70. so again it avoids blocking
them overlooking to those windows
and that's the existing rear elevation
of number 70 again and the existing
building and this is the relationship
you'd get there
um with the proposed development so it
is again showing that there would be no
adverse impact on the existing Windows
um in number 70 and this bit is a rear
projection which projects further back
than the existing the proposed building
will
so
this is the George Street elevation as
proposed on top and this is High Street
elevation so just to cover off some
points
it's taken in our office's opinion an
unsympathetic building that's in the
conservation a highly prominent Corner
location and turning it into something
that has
um a bit of flair and design it to some
extent brings back the sort of
development that was traditionally on
that corner which was smaller sort of
terrorist units that turned the corner
it has traditional proportions it has
traditional materials brick render and
slate proposed
um
comments have been made obviously about
the mix of units and the lack of
affordability a viability assessment was
submitted to the council and obviously
members have seen the assessment from
other independent assessor on that and
it was found with the contribution to
afford a provision of affordable it
would not be viable and the mix of units
um if they were to change the mix of
units it would be unlikely to be viable
but we do have a unilateral undertaking
which gives the Sam contribution and the
contributions requested by KCC as well
as the contribution for the NHS ccg
contribution and an open space
contribution to off-site provision as
well as providing a small area of open
space
on the
application site itself so on balance
members the recommendation is for
approval thank you thank you very much
Annabelle I moved the office's
recommendation which you've heard is for
approval the vice chair please second
I'll second nature thank you write a few
hands going up there with me
counselor Paul more
yes thank you I've got a swathe of
things to to say about the development
firstly I'd like confirmation on the
High Street scene where the buildings
are abutting at the moment obviously
there'll be some kind of party wall
agreement and on the new development it
will be a seamless joint again so
there's a seamless flow from the
existing building to the new one
secondly I have to agree with quite a
few of the comments that Council Austin
said in the fact that what it's being
presented what's being put forward is a
complete transformation of that area of
the High Street which is only going to
improve it and it's very difficult to do
adaptation on an existing building it
can be more costly so what the developer
and the owner have put forward I think
is very good the negativity which again
counter Austin said is that one bedroom
apartments or passe
you meet someone you two people live in
a one-bedroom flat that inevitable
happens you have children you have to
move because you haven't got that
additional room and I don't think
there's a right mix with one bedroom and
two beds and I'd like to see more two
bedrooms in the development
um so on that basis I wouldn't be able
to agree to the recommendation because I
don't think there's a nice a correct
mixture of affordable apartments and the
other hospital question is are there any
social properties in this one for the
number of properties that's being
developed are some being given to social
housing or is it all for people to buy
so that those are my sort of questions
if if I've got it in the right order
thank you chair can you
yep
coming over to you so I'm just going to
come back on the question of mix and so
there's no uh there's no affordable
housing in the site so in terms of what
you're referring to in terms of social
rent so properties to go to ourselves
there's no on-site provision of
affordable housing or off-site
contribution and so that's uh dealt
within the report by virtue of the
viability appraisal that's been done
um this is obviously members we've
talked about this a number of times
um you know this this has been looked at
and specifically we've looked at the
point to do with profit levels so I know
this has been a concern that members are
raised previously The Profit projection
for the developer in this instance in
the appraisal is is 15 on Gross
development value which is the lowest
end of the 15 to 20 percent that is
cited in the mppg and the government
guidance on this
um in terms of values on the site it's
coming over the amount that's found in
the local area but kazlaus has pointed
out there are obviously there's no
precise comparable but it has come over
the value have been put above that but
fundamentally the issue with this site
relates to both build costs and also the
comparison with The Benchmark land value
which obviously it's a commercial site
it attracts a certain value at the
moment therefore any what's left
residual land value
after the viability assessment has to be
compared to that Benchmark land value
and it simply wouldn't Stack Up
therefore to have affordable housing on
site which reduces obviously the amount
of gdv that comes in as opposed to
Market units that does have a knock-on
impact with the argument about mix
because obviously the mix that's been
proposed indeed does have a higher
proportion of one bedroom units than the
Strategic housing market assessment for
the whole local plan would would look
for policy SP 22 specifically talks
about needing to justify Flats as a
greater proportion of development rather
than for example houses in this instance
obviously it's been shown that the
development can just about make it
through and be deliverable providing
some contributions but no affordable
housing on site on the basis of the
units that have been shown if units were
to reduce or change in proportion
obviously if you create two bed unit
you're going to lose one one bed to do
that then the site becomes even less
viable and obviously in this instance
there are two big things in support of
the application in our view one is the
impact on the conservation area and the
beneficial impact there's also the fact
that government guidance is very clear
in the MPP about effective use of
Brownfield sites developing it for high
density development which and the
wording is specific in the mppf is
substantial weight should be given to
those sorts of proposals
given the council's position with
regards to five-year Supply it does
therefore weigh quite heavily on that to
council Moore's point with regards to
impact on the listed building it was
mentioned by Annabelle in terms of a
condition specifically about how are
they going to demolish that building and
construct the new building up against it
it's not quite flush because the
building at the moment isn't flush
adjacent to it so it will match the
footprint of the existing building in
terms of that relationship with with
that building
[Music]
yeah I've got a nursery school down the
road from from there and it's quite sad
seeing the building sort of empty
um I agree with the the office officers
um I mean there is a property opposite
there uh that was I think the Council
made them rebuild build that one or I
don't know opposite which they've
completely rebuild and looks looks very
good
um again you know we're going back to
our previous case where we're saying the
same we've got no developers that are
willing to put money into the into the
area and I think this is a nice scheme
so I would be supporting it thank you
Council Crittenden
thank you
um
rather like councilor Austin has said
um this is a
got mixed um reviews to it just to put
this into context of where this site is
it is right on the edge of the area
where parking is not required to be a
consideration
there's an awful lot of properties
within it I think it's 39. if it we
can't stop people having cars if if even
if half of the people have got cars
that's 20 20 cars Meeting Street Car
Park was referred to and it's extremely
close and I agree but if you put 20 cars
in there you filled half that car park
that is a dinky little car park at best
although this is in a town center
you're talking about a 10-minute walk to
the nearest supermarkets that is
waitrose Iceland Aldi and you're talking
about an uphill walk back there are no
buses
unfortunately I'm saying these things
and I know I can see a new expression on
your face I know these are not reasons
to turn down the um an application but
they are exactly as the applicant has
said this is a national problem but we
are seeing Our Town Center in Ramsgate
increasingly residential and it's not
just this site it's what we've already
referred to as the top of the High
Street and all down King Street and it
is becoming a major problem that we are
we've we've just approved one in Margate
with 10 parking spaces and I'm just
really massively disappointed and I
needed to have my say so thank you very
much
um it is I do appreciate the whole thing
you've said it before Brownfield sites
in Townsend any Brownfield site is
harder to achieve the affordable housing
I understand that it's unfortunate but
um I get it
um
and yeah it's okay I mean
I've got used to the old buildings being
there but I we are turning out we are
turning Ramsgate Town Center into a
residential area and we are not taking
account of it and yes we have got car
Parks but
um it's there are no buses
Council bayford
thank you chair well
I I
agree about the um the lack of need of
one bed flat so I think we do need them
I think
um we attract
business people single people and we
build lots of beautiful homes for
families I think
there is also a need for red Flats I
think this is very attractive I think
it's very good use of the land a great
Improvement I thoroughly supportive
thank you I think it counts both custom
wings uh I'm not gonna go over what uh
Council rosting said because obviously
it's we share the world so I agree with
everything she says but I get quite
annoyed with this based on need we're
not basing anything I need we're basing
things on profit often uh we
commissioned a report that in 2021 that
actually pointed out I found it on a
Google search actually but it was
commissioned by TDC and the growth in
our population is going to be 10 up to
2040 and the main driver is going to be
over 65s which surprised me but it was a
report we commissioned uh so one of the
questions I'm going to ask is are there
any disability or age-proofed uh units
within this development I overall I I
admire this developer for for trying to
repurpose the Town Center because the
big The Big Empty resident With The Big
Empty uh retail units I've been left and
we need to do something and overall I
think this is a positive development I'd
also like to quote the local plan again
as I always do for 116 people that work
in thanet a hundred of them have to
travel outside of the area to work we
don't have the sort of public transport
that would exist in London boroughs you
know you can't even get direct to
Canterbury very often so people are not
although I would like people not to have
cars the reality is people have to have
cars to work the other issue I'm finding
as a ward counselor in another large
development on off Effingham Street was
the over the over
the over purchase of these units to be
turned into airbnbs in one part of the
Effingham Street development there of I
think there were 40 units 30 of them
were being operated as an Airbnb so what
I would try and encourage the developer
to do to put some sort of condition that
that properties can't be sublet for uh
for for airbnbs it happens in other
buildings we stopped that the the
permanent residents that are living in
there are their lives are being blighted
by a constant turnover of
very often young people coming into our
town uh so I think they're the main
questions the parking the parking is a
is a is a big one can we at least have
some parking uh we you know most
developments of this size have at least
some parking as a token I agree with the
developer that we need political
Solutions and I'm looking forward very
much to the parking survey that's been
promised for the last six months
following following following the motion
that was proposed and I and I know this
particular developer has offered some
exciting Solutions
involving some of our own assets that
would help the parking issues we are the
second most dense uh area than it behind
Dartford dartford's not surrounded by
sea on three sides and I know my ward
Central Harbor is amongst one of the
most dense in thanet so we really need
to think seriously about about future
issues so to go over are there any
disability or age proof residents units
in there I would like to see at least
some parking there as a as a token at
least
uh and I can't think what the other one
was
airbnbs that's a real vital one that we
try and the developer I suppose I'm
appealing to the developer here because
it's not a condition we can have but
please also is it managed so bins are
going to be taken to one place so um is
this going to be a a site that is going
to have
a management company looking after it so
making sure that those bins go out to
the store and then come back because if
there isn't we all know those bins are
not going to go there
thank you sorry
don't worry thank you Council wing
uh yes I'll try and hopefully answer
them in the same order and in terms of a
accessible and adaptable units there are
four a requirement for four units to
actually be provided and that's been
agreed but there is also a lift so some
of the other units that aren't
necessarily going to be the accessible
adaptable units can be accessed
now I don't think that we can make them
provide parking there isn't any real
outdoor space the space that is there
would is sort of housing the
um amenity space that's been proposed
and that's the benefit which you
wouldn't normally get in these sorts of
locations and in terms of The Refuge
there's not a sort of management
flat on site or something like that but
there is a team that will come down and
take the bins put the bins out and bring
them back in on the days yes so they
just not left out on site so it's not a
resident's responsibility
I think Annabelle
cancer Everett
thank you chair um yeah I mean it is
obviously visually an improvement on
what's there and and to that extent is
to be welcomed
um I don't have a problem with it in
terms of it being over development I do
share the concerns that have been
expressed about the number of one bed
units
um but the reason that we've got so much
residential coming into our town center
apart from the fact that it's thought to
be a good thing in terms of creating
thriving Town centers
um is that there is a declining demand
for retail and one of the questions
which is for our policies really and not
for this planning application is whether
we should be requiring retail on that
site at this point and I don't know what
the demand for those retail units is I'm
sure the developer has got a better idea
than me and that they're more suitable
than what's there at the moment but
obviously it's our policy which is
keeping that those retail units at
ground floor and protect possibly if
they weren't retail units the building
would be more viable and then we might
get some social housing so all these
things are balances that we have to draw
on the hull there isn't a shortage of
parking in the Town Center I accept that
the meeting street car park is
particularly small and that people who
bring cars will have to pay to park
their cars which they'll do in Council
car parts which is obviously not a bad
thing from the council's point of view
but is an additional cost for them so I
should be supporting the application I
do so with a heavy heart because I don't
like supporting schemes that don't have
any social housing in them but
fundamentally the problem with social
housing is caused by government policy
we need to build more social housing and
not depend on just on developers to
provide it so I don't think we can bring
this particular developer for that thank
you thank you account thank you Council
town and yes I've got your label
but
thank you chair I think it's a it's a
very interesting attractive uh
development and uh with a big use of uh
retail and housing I I feel that it's a
good thing for Ramsgate uh as far as the
uh mix goes I mean you know it's the
best they're making of that building uh
and they're actually producing enough
residential uh requirements to the area
I mean it's interesting to hear uh trade
uh sorry counselor Austin talking about
parking well you know I mean you can't
have it both ways I mean they don't like
cars on the road so they don't need
parking you know so there is no need for
parking because there won't be any over
here so we we don't have that issue with
worrying about pollution and other
things on this particular area and I
would certainly recommend that we
approve this uh uh particular project
thank you thank you Council Italian
didn't you want to come back no we don't
okay
no more speakers
and I did see you that time all right
Rado members I'm going to put this to
you it is uh recommended for approval
will you please show if you're in favor
those against
are against abstentions
that has been carried thank you very
much members uh that brings us to a
close planning committee this evening
can I thank you members officers
uh long long meeting but yep
and take care till the next time good
night